this is jonco podcast number 304 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening also joining
us tonight dave burke good evening dave
good evening
we're going to continue
our review of the book on the psychology
of military incompetence we started that
on the last last podcast
um
believe it or not we only got through
the forward and the preface and two
chapters
uh so
this one could take a while
but
there's a reason there's a reason i've
been sitting on this book for a while
there's a reason i'm doing this podcast
right now
and so today we're going to get
through
some of the first part of the meat of
the book which is the historical
examples
and these historical examples are what
get referred back to throughout this
entire book
so
each one of these
each one of these situations that we're
going to talk about they're broken into
chapters in most cases not 100 but
these are disastrous military
engagements engagements or battles or
campaigns or wars and each one each one
of these
events could be an entire book
and that means they could be
each event could be a podcast or two or
three
and some of them have been you'll you'll
notice some of them that we that we'll
talk about we have done podcasts on
because they're significant military
events some of them i'm sure we'll come
back and visit in the future
and i'm gonna move
[Music]
i'm trying to give enough information in
from each one of these events
so that when he refers back to these
events later you get it because if you
don't have the context then you won't
understand the references that he's
making
so
i'll try and condense the historical
examples a little bit but
it's it's rough and some of them are
really obvious for instance the the
section on
like world war one
considering what world war one is
it's
it's relatively short why because most
of us know
the basic history of world war one same
thing with world war ii
uh but then he gives more specific
examples inside of each of those and
uh outside of those wars that are
definitely more detailed
and
the this section of the book starts with
an epic example of incompetence and
tragedy
it is about the crimean war
including the famous or infamous
depending on
who reads you the story charge of the
light brigade
so this war was fought
between october 1853 and february 1856
between russia on one side
who eventually lost to an alliance of
france the ottoman empire great britain
and sardinia
and so we're going to get into it in the
book
um
the crimean war
certainly marked an exceedingly low port
low point in british military history
the poor quality of the officers most of
whom had bought their commissions and
for whom no standard of education was
required stood in marked contrast to the
excellence of the men
described by one observer as the finest
soldiers i ever saw in stature physique
and appearance so so right out of the
gate we don't like this scenario how do
you get to be in a leadership position
you pay money
that's how you get to be in a leadership
position
your dad is a rich whatever
and so you're a spoiled punk-ass kid
and your dad wants you to have some
clout in the world so he says oh i'm
gonna buy you a commission and by the
way the more money he has the more rank
you get
savage
amongst but yeah he's also saying that
the the men were squared away
amongst the officers there seemed to be
an inverse relationship between rank and
efficiency the more senior they were the
less competent they appeared at the apex
of this pyramid of mediocrity stood or
rather sat for he was always on his
horse or in his quarters and being
inordinately shy rarely walked amongst
his men lord raglan
his qualifications for leading a british
expeditionary force appear to have been
his age
67.
his lineage he was the youngest of duke
of buford's 11 sons and has experienced
25 years as military secretary to the
duke of wellington and then master
general of ordnance no one would accuse
him of having a mind cluttered by any
previous experience of command
before he had none not even of a company
so this guy raglan
which is a bummer because
raglan is the name of an awesome surf
spot in new zealand it's also a name of
one of my favorite restaurants in san
diego which is named after the surf spot
not after
not after lord not after the lord yes
sir lord raglan
raglan obi shout out
his appointment however
was not wholly inappropriate for of him
it was said his chief merit was that
despite his incurable habit throughout
the campaign of referring to the enemy
as the french
which by the way with the enemy was the
russians and and and the french were on
his side
he was admittedly and admirably adapted
to lessen the friction in coalition wars
so this is a guy that was sort of
you know easy to get along with
right they oh you got a bunch of people
we got the french we got the sardinians
we got the ottoman empire we got england
let's put somebody in charge that kind
of can make friends so that's his
admirable
quality
in fact raglan seemed to agree with the
with most french proposals
it was a characteristic of the man that
he hated conflict
so many weird things in all these
different personalities it is just
you know i was on ef online today or
sorry extreme ownership academy today
and uh somebody brought up one of those
personality
tests
and so he was saying you know we we had
a company off site and we did this
personality test and it made me start
thinking about hey when i'm interacting
with someone else
i need to think about what type of
personality they have
and try and
relate things in a way that will best
land on their personality and i said yes
absolutely and then on top of
that add
78 other items who is this person what's
their personality type sure what's their
experience what's their background what
kind of day are they having today what's
their what's their position in the
organization what's my relationship with
them because what we're dealing with
when you're dealing with other human
beings is
that that thing that we talked about on
the underground podcast which is
we're all insane because we all see the
world a little bit differently so when
i'm relating to dave
i can't just think oh it's just i need
to relate to his personality but
how does he feel about this project
what's his passion level what's his
experience how much does he know has he
had bad experience
with this department that he's going to
go take charge of all those things you
have to think about when you're going
into these situations dealing with other
human beings
it's a disaster
yeah we say hum we say leadership human
nature endeavor all the time
and this idea of even just contemplating
how the other person is going to react
is a huge step in the right direction oh
and it's it's shocking how many people
you know that's really what you that's
really what you get when you get the
young
inexperienced leader
they're seeing everything just through
their own eyes and everyone just
what is wrong with everyone oh i'll tell
you what's wrong
they're humans yeah
fast forward a little bit if raglan and
his staff constituted the nerve center
of the army of in the crimea the sinews
compromised a field force of five
infantry and two cavalry divisions under
commanders who for the most part did
little to inspire confidence
here too the problem was partly one of
age apart from the 35 year old duke of
cambridge cousin to the queen all the
senior commanders were between 60 and 70
with sir john
burgoyne chief engineer topping the list
at 72.
certainly it could be said of them that
what they lacked in experience they made
up for in years so
am i am i committing ageism right now
by saying hey if you're 72 and you're in
a war that's taking place in
maybe you're not in the best of health
and maybe you shouldn't be running a war
um check
as i i think a lot of times in these
wars back in the day
like if you're a british lord or
whatever this is just going to check the
box right oh you can go out and you know
kill some natives and be a hero for the
king or for the crown right some of that
is definitely going on
as
has so often been the case the next
lower level of command did contain some
legal leaders of vigor with a talent for
war such one was sir colin campbell
his command unfortunately was no larger
than a brigade as usual in those days
the cream of the crop of the army was
the cavalry commanded in this instance
by lord lucan
an impulsive man of moderate intellect
and lacking experience
there you go that's a good way to start
directly under lucan
in charge of the heavy and light
brigades respectively were james
scarlett and lord cardigan the the
arrangement was not a happy one to
select cardigan for a position
subservient to his brother-in-law lucan
was hardly
less fallicious than subordinating a
mongoose to a snake so you have these
two
relatives that hate each other
and one's been put in charge of the
other lord lucan's been put in charge of
lord cardigan
fast forward a little bit the prime
characteristic of lord raglan
his almost compulsive non-participation
aristocratic courteous and aloof he
seemed to display many of the
characteristics of the extreme introvert
so distasteful was it to have any direct
contact with his fellow men that he
could hardly bear to issue an order and
when he did so it was couched in such a
way to ensure a vast gulf between his
wishes and the comprehension of those
for whom it was intended think about
that you're giving orders that
basically make no sense
it's insanity
it's a it's a it's the opposite of
simple clear and concise
um
this first battle was won by england
but
it it was uh
not exactly it didn't exactly go
the way they wanted it to um that battle
was at alma despite the fact that raglan
watching from afar played little part in
bringing about alma was a victory for
the allies
thanks to the courage and superb
fighting qualities of the soldiers and
their junior officers
through what one observer described as a
great want of generalship the victory
was achieved with much unnecessary loss
of life even worse beca and even worse
because of a total failure to follow it
up yielded few if any dividends for the
campaign as a whole so they were able to
win the battle this first battle only
because the soldiers and the junior
officers were freaking squared away and
brave
and that's a that's a thing that you get
throughout these throughout this book is
the bravery of the soldiers is
undeniable
but they get put in situations that are
just disastrous
there is one final point of some
relevance to the thesis of this book it
concerns the matter of initiative lack
of direction from those at the apex of a
hierarchical authoritarian organization
provides a special dilemma for those at
lower levels in the chain of command
confronted with the absence of clear-cut
orders what are they to do so you're in
a hardcore hierarchy and there's no
clear-cut orders what are you supposed
to do
if they take the law into their own
hands
they run the risk of being accused of
insubordination particularly if their
plans happen to miscarry
but if they do not show initiative then
they are equally likely to suffer for
not having done so at alma the field
officers for want of higher direction
use their own initiative with
considerable success in doing so they
saved the day if not the campaign
this is what we set up in organizations
when we're micromanaging people
and all of a sudden you can't get the
word out what is what are people
supposed to do
if you've trained them to get
micromanaged they're not going to do
anything
uh fast forward a little bit trouble
started in dividing command between the
two generals lord lucan and lord
cardigan already mentioned them
individually neither was fitted to his
post together they were a disaster as
one of their fellow officers wrote in
his diary the more the more i see of
lord lucan and lord cardigan the more i
thoroughly despise them such crass
ignorance and such overbearing temper
raglan did not excel in dealing with
these men instead of loyally supporting
lucan he appeared to condone even the
most flagrant excesses of the
incorrigible cardigan so he's got the
senior officer which is lucan and
instead of like okay you know what
you're just gonna support the chain of
command here instead he sort of lets
cardigan run wild as well
not only did he allow cardigan to bring
his private yacht into bakla balaclava
where for weeks it took up valuable
space in the congested harbor but he
also permitted him to live on board even
while his brigade and divisional
commander were roughing it ashore on
rations under canvas
i like how dave is just closing his eyes
and shaking his head throughout this
by forfeiting his position of authority
and exacerbating the already bitter
enmity between his subordinates raglan's
laissez-faire handling of these
relatively minor matters sowed the seas
of the ultimate disaster the destruction
of the light brigade
so
look we've heard some crazy stuff but
when your troops and your leadership and
your subordinate leadership are living
off rations
intense and you're in a freaking yacht
in the harbor
you can't make that up dude
that is a level of
crazy that you almost couldn't believe
and we were hearing stories about like
they were bringing pianos and like you
know gramophones and stuff like wow
that's pretty excessive
and now you got my i need my personal
yacht in the harbor and i'm going to
live on it yeah
man
that's rough have you ever been on a
yacht before
not like a real yacht no echo charles
yes sir i have but yeah i've been on a
yacht
and
let's just say it's not exactly roughing
no no sir
freaking crazy
um
fast forward a little bit for behind the
color and the glory behind the valor and
the dash the charge of the light brigade
was a blunder of monumental proportions
and an object lesson in what can happen
when the promotional machinery of a
military organization
is such as to put troops at the mercy of
men like raglan lucan and cardigan and
there's a book actually late always
wants to cover this book on on the
podcast to charge the light brigade
you get into the details of these it's
it's
it's insane it's totally insane
here's a little
a little brief of it the explanation of
this curious lapse hinges upon the fact
that lucan had oppressed upon cardigan
that his job was to stay put and defend
the position attacking only such enemy
forces as came within reach under the
circumstances cardigan determined that
he would not give his brother-in-law the
slightest grounds for making a complaint
should the attack fail if it did then
lucan should take the blame lucan had
ordered him to defend the position and
defend it he would even if it cost him
his life
haven't i said before
some people they would rather die than
let their ego
get get offended here's a classic
example
it seems that the charge of the light
brigade from which only 15 percent of
the original force of 673 rode back was
the end result of faulty communication
between five men five men raglan his
quartermaster general aery lords
lieutenant cardigan and the impetuous
captain nolan raglin's contribution is
that he issued orders the precise
meaning of which has remained a matter
for debate
the fourth and more disastrous of these
orders arie wrote out on a flimsy piece
of paper in doing so he made no attempt
to unravel the enigma posed by the words
of his master
and
the um
i'm trying to see if they have this in
here yeah raglan says cavalry to advance
and take advantage of any opportunity to
cover the heights they will be supported
by the infantry which have been ordered
to advance on two fronts
that is the vaguest of vague orders
right there uh as they're trying to sort
through this which front what guns in
its new written form the order was then
passed to the unbalanced captain nolan
who loathed both lucan and cardigan
this glittering young officer of the
15th hussars who made up in arrogance
what he lacked in perspacity
delivered the order to lord lucan luken
whose comprehension of raglan's wishes
seems to have been minimal but who is
not going to demean himself by bandying
words with nolan conveyed his
interpretation of the order to cardigan
this is like the telephone game you play
when you're a kid cardigan with a bunch
of ego
cardigan
to give him his due realizing that he
was being asked to charge the russian
guns down a valley flanked by artillery
expl expressed considerable astonishment
at what would so evidently be the coup
de gras for his
brigade
but once again communication foundered
on the rocks of mutual dislike pride and
jealousy
joined and then overtaken by the
irrepressible nolan cardigan led his
brigade into the jaws of death
um
there's a little section here on a
portioning of the blame
like what do you do
and he says this and it's a very
interesting
thing
to be talking about in this book
because well you'll see it's a very sad
feature of authoritarian organizations
that their nature inevitably
militates against the possibility of
learning from experience through the
apportioning of blame
so hi these these authoritarian
organizations can't learn
from mistakes because they just blame
each other well this is extreme owner
the opposite of extreme ownership this
is extreme disownership the reason is
not hard to find since authoritarianism
itself is the product of psychological
defensive defenses authoritarian
organizations are past masters at
deflecting blame
they do but so by denial by
rationalization by making scapegoats or
by some mixture of the three wow
this is why the book extreme ownership
has hit
a mark
because it's the opposite of this
denial rationalization making scapegoats
or by some mixture of this the three
however it is achieved the net result is
that no real admission of failure or
incompetence is ever made by those who
are really responsible hence
nothing can be done about preventing a
reoccurrence
in this instance as many others to be
considered presently scapegoats were
found one of them was captain nolan an
easy choice since he had very
considerably allowed himself to be
killed
i mean you can't
you can't make this up you can't make
this up the fact that the book extreme
ownership and the concept of extreme
ownership
is
literally the opposite of the
psychopathology
of bad leadership
and the people like even in the you know
i did a ted talk about extreme ownership
and sort of part of that is
no one takes ownership of the problems
and therefore the problems don't get
solved that's what this just said in
more words because
because uh no dr nixon is smarter than i
am
not the only problem
another thing going on that mean meaning
the charge of the light brigade was not
the only
bad situation that unfolded in the
crimean war the crimean missan
mismanagement reached its apogee not in
the battle so far considered but in the
winter and by the way i'm skipping some
battles he gives more detail not in the
battle so considered but in the winter
which followed them despite the fact
that between october 1854 and april 1855
there was no fighting whatsoever
raglan's army suffered a 35 decline in
its active strength this loss was due to
a total disregard for the army's
physical welfare and refusal to
ameliorate the cold and wet of a russian
winter
men died of cholera exposure
malnutrition they died of untreated
wounds of scurvy gangrene and dysentery
as one surgeon observed of the early
losses at balaclava we now bury three
times the number of men every week and
think nothing of it and that's not from
combat
that's just from people dying
according to one writer what killed more
men than russian bullets what made life
miserable what sent men in the hundreds
to the hospital tent or the grave
they were frequently synonymous was want
of firewood without it not only were men
never warm not only could they never
cook their ration of cold grunter but
they were never dry one of raglan's
colonels wrote they go down to the
trenches wet come back wet go into the
hospital wet die the same night and are
buried in their wet blankets the next
morning
and an army surgeon wrote i never
thought the human subject would endure
so much privation and suffering
and we have to remember this is when
freaking england is a superpower this
isn't like some ragtag military unit
hey what's exposure when you die like
cold either cold hot
you know if you're out in the tundra the
freezing tundra you die of being too
cold that's exposure if you're out in
the desert you're exposed to heat you
can dye it
just the elements in general elements in
general yeah
you probably wouldn't know about that
growing up in hawaii no because like
you're not gonna die from
exposure go sleep in exposure
it's all good
back to the book eventually after a
winner of terrible privation raglan's
army came to the last battles of the war
those of redden
they involved the storming and capture
of a fortress on the outskirts of
sebastopol
it seems that little had been learned
again there was gross underestimation of
the enemy's ability indeed the
forthcoming engagement was regarded with
such equanimity that it attracted a
large assembly of sightseers
when the band of the rifle brigade
played light music an audience of
officers wives traveling gentlemen and
even a number of serving soldiers took a
position on surrounding hills
raglan with his mind closed to all that
had gone on before
and an enduring overconfidence in in his
army
chose only 400 of his 25 000 men for the
first stage of the battle the occupation
of some quarries from which the assault
on red end would be mounted this proud
economy in manpower was his first
mistake so you got 25 000 people and
you're gonna use 400 of them and by the
way there's people there's a band
playing i don't even know what kind of
music they're playing what do you say
light spirited music
if you're going into combat and you're
not listening to metallica you shouldn't
bring a band
raglan's staff miscalculated the
strength needed to occupy the quarries
and to repel counter-attacks reserves
had been inadequate and unavailable when
most needed little thought had been
given to the selecting of troops to be
used the proportion of veterans was low
many of the officers although
unquestionably brave were young and
inexperienced but it was with the second
stage of the battle the main assault
that things went really wrong
again raglan and other high-ranking
officers underestimated enemy strength
and overestimated the effects of
artillery bombardment with which the he
preceded the attack
nor did he appreciate that between the
bombardment of the russian fort and the
dawn attacked forced upon him by the
french commander the enemy would well be
able to repair their defenses and their
guns
so you can just see mistakes are just
piling up
under the circumstances it was hardly
surprising that the great volume of fire
from the russian guns brought the
british attack to a very bloody halt
it was at this moment just when it was
most needed that raglan's artillery
received an order to cease fire
it was this last blunder which
transformed an aborted attack into a
massacre no longer intimidated enemy
muskets poured a hail of lead into
raglan stricken army
the latter parties moving like snails
beneath their load were moaned down as
they struggled up the slope
thus ended the first battle for red anne
until the most until then the most
disastrous of the war raglan's army had
no illusions as to the incompetence of
their general and his staff a staff
officer wrote we had been told from
headquarters and other high authority
that success was certain
that the arraignment arrangements for
the plan of attack were so perfect that
they must succeed when they when put to
the test they turned out to be so
excretably bad that failure was
inevitable
others described the battle as
mismanaged blotched blungled
feeble and ill-conducted bad business a
bungling disgraceful childish failure
[Applause]
later lord
wellesley wrote
upon this occasion what we asked from
them was beyond the power of men to give
our plan for the attack was simply
idiotic and was bound to fail another
writer has this to say not only was it a
question of defective tactics at
headquarters there was merely ignorance
not merely ignorance
but an entire lack of vision how was it
possible that raglan and those about him
knowing as they ought by this time the
remarkable russian ability to repair
damage overnight could believe that 2
000 soldiers would be able to advance
over a shell
swept glacies 250 yards in length thread
their way through an undestroyed abitus
cross a ditch 20 foot wide and then a
sail an escarpment without preliminary
bombardment
do i mean can you even fathom that sort
of
operational planning
you have to fight you have to think
this is no thought
yeah i i'll be honest with you i'm
having a hard time listening to this and
and
trying to
even capture like the the the seminal
like the the critical portion of this
i'm trying to get in my head like what
is the most critical lesson from this of
all these things that you keep piling on
top of each other of all these insane
things
and
there's a part of me that that that
finds it unbelievable like i am
literally having a hard time believing
this happened knowing that it did
of something i think is probably you
know the biggest lesson in leadership
and something you articulate to people
all the time which is you you actually
have to care about your people more than
yourself that that fundamental belief
not a tactic not not like like a tool
but but the belief that your people
matter more than yourself
and we see that people struggle with
that we see people struggle with that we
do and we try to help them and and
there's an ego and their selfishness and
there are some natural tendencies we
have to fight against but the depth the
gulf between
that idea and this is so far apart that
it's really hard to appreciate
how
how little the perception is that the
things that you're talking about aren't
things they're people like human beings
on your team and and hearing it is it's
hard to comprehend how do you get so
disconnected you know the yacht was like
sort of a funny a little bit like sad
story
but we all know that we i know it's
coming i know what the outcome is so the
culmination of that is how inconceivable
it could be and then how there's a
lesson inside there of
if you don't care about the people
around you you're not going to listen to
them
and how far you can get from that
i mean this isn't this isn't a thousand
years ago yeah
yeah the um
like there's a billion different the the
last section i read it's like oh a
tactical problem tactical problem
tactical problem tackle problem
we get that there's some tackle and
people make tactical mistakes how the
question is how
do you make all these tactical mistakes
the answer is leadership yeah all your
problems are leadership problem and the
solution is leadership
the solution to problems is leadership
and you end up with people that are bad
leaders
in these situations they make bad
decisions and things fall apart and the
other thing we have to think about too
because this is a very
it's a military
thing it's a military idea but
there's there's the men and there's the
mission right
and there's a priority
sometimes people say well you know the
mission is the most important thing
the reality is
that's actually not true
if you prioritize the mission over the
men you won't have any men left and you
won't be able to execute any missions
so
they're mutually supporting things that
need to be
both that both need to be addressed and
taken care of yeah if if now look can
you do can you get a mission where hey
dave you're going to take your assault
team in and you're taking out
this
you know air defense node in north korea
and jocko's team is going to take out
the other defense node and echo's team
is going and if we don't take out these
three defense nodes
we can't like we're not going to
strategically achieved this objective
then it's like okay look we're gonna be
we're gonna be taking some casualties
and look at d-day that's what we did
look the pacific island campaign that's
what people did
but
to look at a situation like this where
there's about 10 000 other ways to
execute this mission
is insane yeah
and if and if
and if you're going through that sort of
mental arm wrestling over the men or the
mission or the people and the mission
the only way you actually get people to
be willing to do that mission
is for them to know that you care about
them more than yourself
and that's too that's your point
is
you're not even saying the mission isn't
as important as the people in in like in
a in a hierarchy you're saying that if
you actually want to be able to
accomplish the most difficult things the
most difficult missions missions that
almost appear unwinnable
if you actually want to be able to do
that which of course we do we're here to
solve solve the problem here to complete
the mission
is to have people willing to do that
and the only way to do that is for them
to go oh
dave actually cares about me more than
just getting the check in the block that
he knocked this thing out or took care
of this one thing or got this mission
solved we can tell his boss yeah mission
accomplished and and you actually have a
better chance of doing things that by
rights almost appear to be impossible
yeah the
the culture that you have inside your
organization
you can have a culture inside your
organization where people are going to
be willing to sacrifice their lives for
your team right and if you look at this
time period with the brits with the
victorian the honor the glory the i mean
when you know
at the beginning phases of world war one
when they would when they would if there
was if you were a military-aged male and
you weren't in the military the women
would give you the the white flower
right which meant you were a coward
and so people were like okay where do i
sign up right and that was kind of the
deal um look at the look at the japanese
in world war ii now were those guys was
those kamikaze pilots brainwashed well
not even just brainwashed but were they
regretful yeah in some cases they were
but also they were committed culturally
to this overarching thing
here's the problem with that
in both those cases
if you as a leader continue to sacrifice
people without making the progress
you end up having to say uh this isn't
working out yeah and the people will
look at you and say wait a second we we
tried this this isn't working you need
to figure out a different plan or we're
not going to do what you tell us to do
um
continuing on here for the student of
the psychosomatic disease the aftermath
of the battle is not without
significance
immediately following the defeat
raglan was seen seen to age visibly
within a few days he had contracted
cholera and before 10 days had passed he
was dead
to his generals were similar similarly
stricken raglan's demise added to the
depression of the army had they known
that his replacement would be 63 year
old general simpson their grief might
have been
more acute
it's not that simpson was a harsh task
masker master
on the contrary he was a gentle old man
but a very mediocre ability he was as
devoid of useful experience as had been
his predecessor his methods were rather
simpler be than those of raglans
presumably to avoid giving a wrong order
he gave no orders at all
and he devised no plan
in the words of one observer he did not
command the army
on the day of his promotion he is
credited with saying
they must indeed be hard up when they
appointed an old man like me
how about you say no
and by the way if the boss doesn't come
up with a plan come up with one
in fact the government was not so hard
up as they had to entrust the army to
this gout gout-ridden old general
a far better choice would have been the
energetic and outspoken sir colin
campbell a man of considerable ability
and wide experience but campbell was a
maverick
and as such was unpopular with the
military establishment
he also came from a relatively humble
background so instead of taking the
freaking george s patton of the crew
you take this loser
under simpson's quavering and
ineffectual hand the second battle for
redden the last battle of the war proved
even more disastrous than the first once
again a massive bombardment was followed
by a frontal assault across a heavily
defended triangle of ground flanked by
russian guns
but this time the troops were younger
and greener and despite all their
training on the parade grounds
of aldershot less inclined to valor
than discretion having sustained
2447 casualties in two hours of fighting
they turned tail and fled
thus adding humiliation to defeat so
that's what i was just talking about
hey we're willing to sacrifice
but but
there's a line
2447 casualties and two hours of
fighting
as an example of protracted military
incompetence at a high level of command
the cream crimean war
is not unfortunately unique it was
however the prototype for subsequent
ineptitude though small in number in
comparison with those of later wars the
18 000 who died owed their ultimate
their untimely demise to end
and mixture of poor planning
unclear orders lack of intelligence
in both senses of the word
and fatal acquiescence to social
pressures on the part of their commander
that's a very interesting topic
social pressures
we see a lot of that going on in this
current time in the military
social and political pressures on war
fighting units who have a job which is
to fight
they died because they were mismanaged
by men whose positions in the military
hierarchy owed less to their ability
than to their wealth their place in
society or their reputation for quote
fitting in
they died because soldiers were too
readily regarded as expendable objects
the crimean
wars the crimean war was fought at a
time
of the greatest prosperity this country
had ever known when british efficiency
inventiveness and sheer entrepreneurial
vigor knew no bounds
as i said earlier this isn't like a
ragtag crew
why then was it fought so badly so badly
that the casual observer might have been
forgiving for thinking that at some
level we did not really want to lit win
of course there are some obvious and
immediate reasons governmental
stinginess clearly played a part
as did the deliberate policy of
entrusting military matters to the to an
aristocratic rich but essentially
amateur elite
this on the grounds that such a class
would neither would have neither the
motivation nor indeed the skill to turn
upon the state
but this is only to touch the surface of
the problem such reasons do not explain
the passivity and non-participation
the monumental errors of judgment the
ludicrous appointments the paralytic
ability to improvise or innovate
they do not explain the staggering and
ultimately self-destroying wastage of
manpower which seems to have its origin
in a curiously detached attitude toward
human suffering finally they do not
explain the even greater depths of
incompetence shown on this occasion by
the enemy of whom it has been said quote
the russians with more men in the field
and immense potential reserves were even
bigger muddlers than their invaders
and seemed to move in a vague dream of
battle
so
this that whole last section
is saying look there were some problems
like maybe the government didn't support
as much maybe there was some some um
some
what do you say
uh governmental stickiness right so
there's some problems
but you should not be losing like that
it doesn't explain all these issues
and especially that last part which says
look the russians were like
crap anyways
it's not like they got beat by the
freaking waffen ss
in 1941.
so there's issue
issues
um
next the next thing that he talks about
in here and again there's so much more
detail in this because you get this book
there's so much more detail
that is important
um
the next section here
chapter four
talks about the boor war
and
we covered the buddha war on podcast 233
the boomer war the brewer army consisted
is an interesting statement about
decentralized command the boor army
consisted of 35 000 generals
each combatant his own
master defending his homeland
there were also they were also good
marksmen agile horsemen and determined
members of a flexible knowledgeable
guerrilla force
so
that's what we're dealing with now the
boors
burma remember that were you waiting for
me to say it
uh well kind of no but that's the
expression in uh
in in in south africa for the boors it's
like they're going to come up with a
plan the boomer makes a plan that's my
afrikaans that's good
but that's the kind of people that
you're fighting you're fighting farmers
you're fighting people that work with
the land that ride horses that shoot
that hunt that's who you're fighting
against freaking legit legit enemy
fast forward a little bit
largely because they eschewed any form
of
sartorial elegance
that means clothing by the way
and preferred the wearing of civilian
attire
dark cloaks and floppy hats to the sorts
of uniforms affected by the british the
boors were dubbed the rabble of the
illiterate peasants and their army
utterly ludicrous so these guys were
just wearing like what they wore in the
field this is like if you went to war
with texas and they showed up wearing
freaking levi's cowboy hats
and wrangler shirts right and you're
like well who are these guys yeah how
are they gonna fall
fast forward a little bit as lord
kishner said
the booers are not like the sudanese who
stood up to a fair fight
they're always running away on their
little ponies
there are good many foreigners among the
boors but they are easily shot as they
do not slink about like the brewers
themselves so here you are complaining
what kind of tactics are these
what are they doing we had to be careful
that
like in iraq was like oh they're running
around just doing these ieds that's
cowardly it's like oh
they work yeah how about that sense
they're not as easily shot
complaining that they're hard to kill
yeah yeah check i guess maybe they know
what they're they're doing yeah it
sounds like they have a good plan yeah
and by the way we did this to them in
the revolutionary war
but just fyi they're england
they're they're lord kishner remember
remember what happened at lexington in
concord
you know we were scurrying around too
and we kind of kicked your ass so you
should have maybe learned some lessons
there
which is one of the points of this whole
book is the fact that there's no lessons
learned
this then was the background of the
attitudes of the expertise the british
army brought to the boomer war any
residual doubts about its unfittedness
for the expedition tend to dissipate
when one considers the behavior of the
generals put in charge the leading
character was the commander in chief
general
sir redverse buller
according to a contemporary description
there could be no finer choice for the
south african adventure
there is no stronger commander in the
british army than this remote almost
grimly resolute completely independent
utterly fearless steadfast and vigorous
man
big boned square jaw strong-minded
strong-headed smartness sagacity
administrative capacity he was born to
be a soldier of the very best english
type needless to say the best type of
all
freaking legit
right
here's the reality
unfortunately this assessment was at
variance with the facts in all but two
particulars firstly he was indeed big
secondly though sadly lacking in moral
courage he was undoubtedly brave when it
came to physical danger in this respect
as in many others he was not unlike
raglan of the crimean war
and indeed some other commanders of
subsequent years
of sir reversabler as he became to be
known so instead of his his name is
redverse they started calling reverse
instead
kruger writes at the risk of marring the
contemporary description it should be
mentioned that his big bones were
particularly well covered especially in
the region of his stomach and that his
square jaw was not especially apparent
above a double chin so this is just like
a fat dude
and they're trying to make him sound
like a badass
um
what was his attitude like fast forward
a little bit buller lost no time in
trying to rid himself of any direct
responsibility for the conduct of the
war by handing over the reins to
subordinate commanders who to whom he
gave no further directives
butler's subordinate
general methuen with eight thousand men
was very nearly defeated by three
thousand booers methuen's objective was
the modern river a natural defense line
for boers accordingly without any
reconnaissance he ordered his troops to
make a frontal attack
are we starting to get off are we
starting to understand the frontal
attack
might not be the best move
since he could not see the enemy
he wrongly assumed that no enemy was
there led by their officers the men
advanced across the flat and open belt
towards the river all went well until
they were within easy range of the boors
who had concealed themselves with what
was subsequently described as a fiendish
cunning below the deep banks of the
river
those of methuen's army who were not
killed outright by the sudden blast of
fire from the invisible bores spent the
day lying prostrate under a scorching
sun in a temperature of 110 unable to
move forward or back they including the
70 wounded suffered extreme
discomfort from thirst and slowly
blistering skin methuen's remedy was to
direct heavy artillery fire on the boor
positions thanks to the latter's use of
cover this barrage had very little
influence on the course of events apart
from killing a number of his own troops
through faulty range finding it was only
under cover of darkness that the british
even eventually withdrew leaving behind
500 dead and wounded
i keep following these little traps as
i'm listening to you
and the trap i keep falling into is you
started up like hey here's this guy in
charge and he's totally incompetent
and he's um he's gonna relinquish the
command and the control this whole
responsibility to his subordinates and
i'm thinking awesome that's awesome i
would love to be that subordinate cool
i've got an incompetent boss but at
least he's letting me be in charge and
the trap i keep falling into is how far
down this goes this this sort of like
illness of the organization that this
leadership it isn't just the people at
the very very top it's all the
subordinate commanders as well because
when i hear you say
you have a weak boss
i i like that kind of fired up cool
that's awesome sweet i'll be in charge
this is great i can and i can do
whatever i want because he doesn't seem
to care
but that's that's i've fallen on that
trap a couple times now hearing you talk
about how far down this goes
of people that have should not be there
for
their dads are buying their position or
whatever it might be
i gotta bring this up i'm gonna bring it
up right now
there's a
underlying this book this book
catches
so many of the themes that i talk about
all the time and that we talk about all
the time
there's
one theme
that i've found throughout this book
that never gets addressed
never gets addressed in this book and
it's an underlying theme
that is so obvious as you read this book
and that is the idea
of detachment
because every one of these military
leaders
as you read the decisions that they're
making and you know that they're all
caught up in their ego and the and their
social structure and the hierarchy and
the actual tactical engagement that
they're in and that what they can see
they make it's so you just sit there and
think hey hold on a second you're gonna
you're gonna move across this open field
that you're an idiot like why are you
doing this
and the reason one of the reasons yes
there's ego yes there's there's
uh a social structure and hierarchy and
bravery and all those things yep they're
all there
but if you are in charge of something
and you don't take a step back to
actually assess what is happening how
it's going to happen
why you're going to do it this way if
you can't detach from these things you
are going to fail and you're going to
fail all the time
and that's one of the only themes
that i talk about that we talk about
that really doesn't get addressed here
he never says hey
and maybe i didn't catch it maybe we'll
catch it the first time because i'm
paying attention to it as we read it but
he never says hey no one took a step
back and looked at this plan
it doesn't really say that which is
a huge red flag
um you know we were talking about this
this commercial is that what it's called
advertisement right
we shot right an advertisement echo
charles was in charge
of an advertisement you were making a a
video for for jackal fuel gonna get some
go right
and i had a small roll you know
small roll one line right through one
leg yep
well
when i i showed up so you guys were kind
of done with the filming and i showed up
to deliver my one line
right yes sir and when i came in i kind
of changed the script
of not my line but of the the
i would say the lead actors line the
straight up ending yeah really
well as i was exp i was trying to
explain is like that's not because i'm
smarter it's not because i'm funnier
it's not because i'm better at writing
it's because i when i came in your mind
is filled with you know first of all
four or five hours of prep what you
think the shots are gonna be right and
writing and then you've been on scene
for how long were you an hour there yeah
so you're on there for an hour you've
got all these different components in
your head you're trying to assemble what
it's going to look like i stroll in
you know
fresh off of like a jocko go i'm kind of
hyped ready to deliver my line
and i hear the ending and i go hmm but
i'm detached and so i'm seeing it from a
bigger perspective and i go hey the
closing line should be this
and you were like
a little bit of resistance a little bit
of resistance because i know it hurts a
little bit well okay go ahead
i was gonna say the resistance was more
like the feeling of momentum you know
how like
okay we got the beginning we got
everybody here it's boom the beginning
then we got the middle you know and the
end is right after this so it's kind of
like things are coming along you know so
we're ready and when we kind of are
writing momentum and you change it it's
like oh shoot we gotta kind of shift and
pivot right as it were so it was kind of
that a little bit but i i did recognize
immediately that that was a good ending
and the only reason i was able to see
that is because i was detached and as i
came in kind of looked at the thing and
saw how it was going like okay
and luckily
you're a humble person you were like
check you weren't like you know what hey
jocko you don't know how the whole thing
goes together hey
hey that's not
what we're looking you know you could
have given me 87 different excuses that
i would have been like okay you know
what i mean i'm not going to impose on
you and just be like change it because
this isn't you know it's not like you're
going to win an oscar for this freaking
ad although maybe you know
so so
but luckily you're humble
and you're you are detached enough to go
hmm okay cool
so that's what
that's one thing that i see that i don't
see in this book i don't see dixon
talking about the fact that
one of the best skills for a person to
have to overcome all these other
problems is being able to detach take a
step back
yes
i was just thinking about and we god we
talk about detachment all the time all
the time
and i i was thinking about these
situations you just described two of
them you know between those two
conflicts the crimean war in the boomer
war
is this idea that detachment only works
that the people on your team are
actually prioritizing the team being
successful over these other things like
the social pressure or or these other
things that i know they sound outlandish
i know that they sound outlandish the
way you're describing this but
but even inside these organizations does
dave like oh man i mean i kind of work
for jocko this is kind of his company
and and
i don't i don't want to i don't want to
make him mad so so go go go yeah here's
what's interesting about what you're
saying
you
because of what we do for a living
you're already aware of those things
right a person that's you're not even
what you just said like wait it's
chocolate that's a detachment you're
assessing what's going on most people
are just they're so caught up they're
like i'm not gonna let dave burke get
control this operation that that's what
that's that's the end state yeah the end
state is i'm not gonna let dave burke
run this thing
or echoes like i'm not going to let
choco chase that's that's it i'm not
going to let choco change the way this
script is going that is it he's that's
the fire fight right there in his head
i'm not going to let jocko dictate
what's happening i'm in charge hey jocko
we're doing it my way that's
that's what happens that's what happens
to these guys yeah the fact of the
matter is they they don't detach so they
can't see it
so it's yes you're right in the fact
that you're right in the fact that
they
they they aren't considering it but the
reason that they're not considering it
is because they can't even see it
because it's all around them it's just
the way they're thinking it's the way
they're thinking which is freaking
horrifying yeah that's the whole
horrifying part
gets worse by the way within a few days
of his performance at modern river he
confirmed his worst the worst fears of
his critics and even more disastrous
battle of
maeger's fortine
makers fontaine sorry to the people of
south africa to the afrikaans i'm sorry
makers funtime
especially for a dutch guy i should be
doing a little bit better the booers
were concealed in a narrow in narrow
trenches
in front of his objective
they waited patiently until the british
came within easy range surprise was
complete when they opened fire a hail of
lead swept through the ranks of the
highland brigade within minutes the
ground was carpeted with dead soldiers
including the highland commander george
woshop
it was too much for the remainder
despite their training and discipline
despite the honor of the regiment
despite all the factors which the high
command finally believed would induce
uneducated soldiers to sacrifice
themselves for the shortcoming of their
generals
they broke ranks turned tail and fled
as they did so they were further pounded
and demoralized
by hitherto undetected batteries of boo
or artillery
fast forward a little bit methuen was by
no means the most foolhardy of the
generals
there was general feather stone
who at the battle of belmont insisted on
riding up and down in front of his men
in full regalia thereby announcing his
importance to the enemy and effectively
hampering the fire of his own men
it was not long before the buu has
rectified his error by shooting off
shooting him off of his horse there was
general hart who at the battle of
kalenso inflicted 30 minutes parade
ground drill on his brigade before
marching them shoulder to shoulder in
barrack square precision across the open
belt against the boo position since it
was broad daylight his densely packed
column provided an irresistible target
for every boor gun and rifle within
range this battle
in this battle the british were defeated
with a loss of
1139 casualties and 10 guns
against the boor losses of six dead and
21 wounded
fast forward a little bit it is at this
point it becomes necessary to introduce
another concept which is relevant to the
contact of the south african war it is
that of the effects of psychological
stress upon decision making it is
perhaps their resistance to stress and
their ability to carry on when things go
wrong that good generals are most easily
distinguished from poor ones
which by the way if you can detach
that's what's going to allow you to do
that by this standard general buller
physically so huge failed dismally
irresolute from the outset the three
defeats
sapped whatever confidence he ever had
from being weak and fearful he became a
veritable jelly of indecision his plans
became vague and indefinite his specific
orders scarcely more enlightening his
lack of moral courage in the face of
adversity revealed itself most clearly
in his propensity for making scapegoats
of his unfortunate subordinates those
admittedly incompetent generals who had
blundered on without direction or
assistance from above while taking down
the blame himself again the
direct antithesis of extreme ownership
the nearest to such admission was a
reference to bad luck
bad luck it may have been but worst luck
was to follow in the shape of that 1 400
foot monument to miller military
ineptitude spying cop
the totally unnecessary storming of this
mini mountain was to the boo or war what
the charge of the light brigade had been
in the crimean war
the details are as followed
while still
numbed by the series of defeats just
recounted buller's army of 29 000
infantry 2600 mounted men eight field
batteries and ten naval guns was
enriched if that is the word by the
arrival of a fresh division commanded by
chur sir charles warren
fast forward a little bit the plan was
went wrong for several reasons in the
first place warren's division was far
too small for the main attack the second
reason for disaster lay in the character
of warren
who's been described as a dilatory yet
fidgety over cautious yet is
irresolute and totally ignorant
regarding the use of cavalry
he was also obsessive obstinate
self-opinionated and excessively bad
tempered isn't it interesting how you
hear bad temper a lot when this guy is
describing freaking knucklehead leaders
um
this also included an obsession with
enormous baggage train
and fear that it might be destroyed by a
non-existent enemy
by non-existent enemy guns on
the small mountains spy on cop so
concerned was he with his baggage that
he spent 26 hours personally supervising
its transfer across the river the delay
was invaluable to the boers so yeah this
is the guy that had um
you know
pianos longhorned gramophones chests of
drawers polo sticks
like this is one of those guys and so
he's trying to make sure that all of his
baggage is getting where it needs to be
and personally supervising this freaking
savage
fast forward a little bit so while the
general stayed below the men were
ordered up the steeply sloping
mountainside so he kind of thought that
we needed to take this this high ground
spy and cop
seems like a good call
the men were ordered up the steeply
sloping mountainside into a fog hardly
less dense than that which clouded the
minds of their commanders when in almost
zero visibility they thought they had
reached the summit the assault force
halted congratulated themselves
on the total absence of opposition
raised the union track jack and tried to
entrench
the word the operative word is tried for
the top was much like the rest of the
mountain solid rock nobody had warned
them of this by the way he didn't do a
recon just fyi
they decided to use sandbags only to
find that no one had remembered to bring
them
while the mist cleared they did the best
they could with pieces of rocks and
clods of earth only too well aware that
this flimsy protection provided no
overhead cover whatsoever if this gave
them food for thought there was more to
follow for with a further improvement in
visibility they made a second
disquieting discovery
they were not where they thought they
were instead of the summit they found
themselves on a small plateau some way
below the mountaintop 1 700 men on a
piece of ground 400 by 500 yards and
above them on three sides
the boors
the enemy opened fire within minutes the
ground was littered with corpses many
with bullet holes in the side of the
head or body owing to the lack of
overhead cover the losses from shrapnel
were even greater trapped in this
seemingly hopeless position without any
guidance or directives from their
general the 200 lancaster fusiliers laid
down their arms and surrendered to the
brewers
this their place was taken by
reinforcements sent up from below
meanwhile warren and bullard did nothing
to help the hard-pressed troops no doubt
appalled by what was happening to his
army on the heights above warren supine
at the best of times went into a state
that has been described as paralytic
important note a war correspondent who
had witnessed the dire events on top of
the mountain hurried down to the
commanding general but instead of
receiving this admittedly unsolicited
information with gratitude warren flew
into a rage and demanded that the
journalist should be arrested for
insolence
name of the war correspondent was
winston churchill
but before moving on to the next example
it's worth placing the crimean and boor
wars in the same perspective both
present a picture of what appears to be
unrelieved stupidity
but more interesting is the
psychological pattern of these events
here was a rich and powerful nation
anxious to assert assert its rights
first in russia than in south africa
what did it do but send out highly
regimented armies which endeavored to
make up encourage discipline and visual
splendor what they lacked in relevant
training technology and adequate
leadership
as to the latter in each case a
commander-in-chief was selected who
despite his deficiencies remained
inordinately popular with his troops for
far longer than he deserved both men
were genial courteous and kind both were
inexperienced as irresolute and lacking
moral courage both were rich and well
connected but both when the occasion
demanded were only too ready to divest
themselves of all responsibility for the
errors which they had made
and the one seemed quite unable to learn
from the mistakes of the other
from the moment
it might prove helpful to keep in mind
certain characteristics of the
incompetence just described they include
so here's as we get into a list of
problems
number one an underestimation sometimes
bordering on the arrogant of the enemy
check
in equating war with sport oh
that's a good one
an inability to profit from past
experience hello
a resistance to adopting and exploiting
available techno technological
technological and novel tactics
this is just a list of freaking what not
to do an aversion to reconnaissance
coupled with a dislike of intelligence
in both sense of the word and i probably
skipped over there's a lot of situations
where they don't do any recon they're
like oh yeah we know what to do and they
just go and execute
great physical bravery but little moral
courage
an apparent imperviousness by commanders
to loss of life and human suffering
amongst the rank and file or its
converse and irrational and
incapacitating state of compassion
passivity and indecisiveness in their
senior commanders
a tendency to lay blame on others boom
a love of the frontal of sight assault
boom
a love of bull and we we covered a bit
of this but
we brought up the term chicken
actually someone
sent a great i forget what document they
got it from but the the term chicken
is exactly i should have brought
that definition it's exactly what i was
trying to describe the technical
definition of chicken is perfect
it's like meaningless imposed discipline
for the sake of discipline
um i love the smartness i love a bull
smartness
precision and strict preservation of the
quote military pecking order
a high regard for tradition and other
aspects of convert conservatism
a lack of creativity improvisation
inventiveness and open-mindedness
a tendency to eschew moderate risks for
tasks so difficult that failure might
seem excusable
and last but not least procrastination
this is a good
little filter to run yourself through
once a week to see where you're at
just to check on your damn self
what do you got dave i'm literally
writing
what the so as you went through that
list i tried to just as quickly as i
could just make the connection
humility humility innovate adapt default
aggressive humility cover and move
dichotomy stream ownership direct
approach innovate adapt detach develop
aggressive discipline
and how quickly and this isn't to like
show how smart i am it's like how easy
it is to make the connection what you
preface this was he kind of i think he
listed three
one was technology i forgot what the
first one was and the third one was
leadership and really the list could
just be one it's leadership
but the title of this book is is that
the title of the book is the psychology
of it it's this it's the it's the
individual's personal psychology and
when we're talking about these things is
how
painful it is to sit from the outside
and watch the hole that they dig or just
how obvious and to your point of
detachment how obvious it is
it's not nuanced it's not like a slight
little adjustment you're just sitting
back here watching this and there is you
know there's zero chance it's gonna work
not because we know the history because
of because of the setup that you're
revealing this is the situation this is
how these people make decisions this is
the way they think like this is gonna
fail
this is gonna fail and how easy it is to
attribute every single one of those to a
basic fundamental leadership behavior
it's disturbing it's disturbing not the
least of which is the one that repeats
itself
more than anything else which is
what you talked about at the very
beginning was humility
just the inability to be humble
it's it's it's hard to listen to you man
yeah
it is very difficult and it's
about to get worse
chapter 5 indian interlude which also
includes a little section on afghanistan
from the data considered so far it might
be thought that military incompetence is
confined to intra-racial conflicts white
against white unfortunately as suggested
by the following account of a minor
incident at the time of the indian
mutiny this particular prediction is not
borne out when it comes to interracial
conflict a pattern of incompetence is
little changed
here is the story of fort rouya
as recounted by p scott o'connor general
walpole
wall pool
walpole who it appears that never before
held the independent command was ordered
to lead an expedition
up the left bank of the ganges river
from
lucknow
to rohick land
[Music]
row hill cland
to clear the rebels out from that part
of the country the brigade set out from
luck now on the 7th of april 1858 and on
the morning of the 15th found itself in
the vicinity of fort rouya the troops
had marched nine miles that morning but
walpole anxious to win his spurs with
the least possible delay sent his force
immediately to the assault
the fort was the residence of a rebel
landholder named narpat singh
he had but 300 followers at his command
but taking advantage of the troubles
which beset the british in india in the
dark days of 1857 he unfurled the flag
of rebellion at rueya
and paid the government defiance his
stronghold was nothing very formidable
on its northern eastern faces was
strongly defended by a high mud wall and
a broad and deep ditch covered by a
dense jungle but from the west and south
it was open to attack
as the wall on those sides were about a
few feet high the defenders relying
mainly on the jahil the waters of which
lapped the fort
to protect them from their enemies
coming from that direction
there were two gates to the fort
and these open on the sides just
mentioned and there is no doubt the
general wall poll delivered the assault
from the direction of the fort
must have been quickly reduced
with but a fraction of casualties which
actually occurred
it was the month of april
and the water of the heel
was every was everywhere very shallow
and in many places dried up so that the
only obstacle to an assaulting party
from that side was lacking so there's
there's uh a place where you can assault
this thing pretty easily because there's
supposed to be a a river there or some
kind of a pond there but it's all dried
up
so
that's the obvious place to usually you
use that for defense but it's not there
it's like you have a moat
but the moat is dried up okay well so
that's where we're going to attack
however back to the book but general
walpole took no trouble to recon order
and even without a cursory examination
examination of the position launched his
men in a blundering haphazard manner
against the strongest face of the fort
the rebels it was reported were prepared
to evacuate the place after firing a few
rounds but when they saw the british
advancing against the face which could
be defended they changed their minds and
determined to show fight
now walpole under the mistaken
impression that there was a gate on the
east side of the fort directed captain
ross grove to advance with the company
of the 42nd highlanders through the wood
in that direction and to hold the gate
and prevent the enemy from escaping the
company advanced in skirmishing order
through the jungle before them and
dashing across the open space of ground
which lay between the forest and the
fort found their progress impeded by the
ditch which had up until that point been
invisible there was no alternative but
to lie down on the edge of the counter
scarp
and there and as there was only a few
paces between them and the enemy
and no shelter whatsoever
they were exposed to a galling fire and
suffered severely they held on to their
position however in a most heroic manner
awaiting the development of the attack
in the other directions but finding
after a time that no other attack was
being made grove sent word to the
general tell him that there was no gate
and requested scaling ladders for an
escalade dude don't talk about a brave
individual
they're freaking
under withering fire and there happens
to be no gate instead of said hey dude
we're out of here he's like hey can you
send us ladders maybe
meanwhile captain cafe
wholly unaware of the ditch which had
checked grove in his advance came up
with his seeks and dashed into it with
no ladders to help them out again they
were shot down without mercy by the
enemy
no orders had yet reached grove nor were
there scaling ladders forthcoming so a
second messenger was dispatched to the
general asking for reinforcements the
general apparently now alarmed at the
consequences of his own rashness hastily
sent the heavy guns around to the west
and ordered a bombardment of the fort
from that side
i'm sure if you're tracking this you can
see what's coming a very natural result
followed some of the balls from the guns
going over the fort fell among our men
on the other side for they had not yet
been withdrawn a report to this effect
was carried to adrian hope
who at once and adrian hope by the way
this is like the the son of uh
of earl
john hope who's like a royal and a very
respected heroic soldier from the
peninsula wars so adrian hope a report
to this effect was carried to adrian
hope who at once wrote off to inform
walpole but from what followed it
appears that latter doubted the accuracy
of the statement for hope immediately
returned to see for himself
it's another thing that you're going to
hear in this book is when you hear
something that doesn't quite fit in you
deny it
this is something we see every damn day
oh it doesn't match your uh
your narrative cool ignore it
good god general
exclaimed grove on seeing him
this is no place for you you must lie
down but the kindly warning came too
late for even at that moment hope fell
back into the speaker's arm shot through
the chest soon after came the order to
retire and general walpole rode back to
camp under the cover of darkness that
night the rebels slipped out of the fort
and made good their escape
the loss the lost the country sustained
by the death of willoughby douglas
bramley harrington and of the hundred
and odd men uselessly sacrificed before
rooyah was great but the loss of adrian
hope was a cause for national sorrow his
death was mourned on the spot by every
man in the camp loud and deep with the
incentives against the obstinate
stupidity which had caused it
general walpole's unhappy expedition was
not the first disaster to befall the
british army in india 16 years
previously in 1842 a catastrophe
occurred beside which the events at fort
ruya seemed scarcely worth a mention
quote the road was strewn with mangled
corpses of their comrades and the stench
of death in the air all along the route
they had been passing little groups of
camp followers starving frostbitten and
many of them in a state of gibbering
idiocy
the afghans
not troubling to kill these stragglers
had simply stripped them and left the
cold to do its work and now the poor
wretches were huddling together naked in
the snow striving hopelessly to keep
warm by the heat of their own bodies
there were women and little children
among them who piteously stretched out
their hands for help later the afghans
were to report with relish that the
unhappy fugitives in their blind
instinct to perform preserve life a
little longer had been reduced to eating
the corpses of their fellows
but they all died in the end
the british retreat from kabul in the
first afghan war was described by field
martial sir general templar as the quote
most disgraceful and humiliating episode
in our history of war against the
against an asian enemy up to that time
end quote judging from the details of
how a british army of 4 500 men was
wiped out by what was in comparison with
the british strength a handful of afghan
tribesmen the field marshal's words were
are nothing of an overstatement
i'm gonna fast forward a little bit so
so what did the british do wrong how did
they end up in this situation in
afghanistan in this worst possible site
the british laid out a camp so they they
had to figure out where they were going
to build a camp and the worst possible
site the british laid out a camp to the
worst possible design
not only was the tomb was the two mile
perimeter a purely nominal obstacle
consisting of a low wall and narrow
ditch far too long to be defended by the
numbers it enclosed but the hole was
open at its northern end to a compound
of dwellings for the british envoy and
his staff this hopped this hodgepodge of
houses positively invited infiltration
by even the least intrepid of enemies to
complete this incorrigible behavior
there had been one final act of such
unbelievable stupidity that its
repercussions
were to lead to the death of an army by
the orders of the commanding officer
willoughby cotton the army's commissar
store stores were constructed a quarter
mile outside the contantment
so they have their camp and they build
they put their supplies a quarter mile
outside the camp
the consequences of this division
decision were tragic and inevitable when
the afghans finally rose up against the
british the army were promptly cut off
from their supplies thus it was under
the threat of starvation that they
ultimately capitulated to akbar khan the
afghan leader and began to retreat which
cost them all their lives
it's
i'm really glad you brought up the
concept of detachment being
maybe just absent from from at least
from an explicit sense of but
you're trying to piece together
how this is possible from a from a a
professional maybe the most professional
military in the world at least
historically at that point yes you know
i mean like you said not a bunch of just
jv dude trying to put some things
together and the only thing i can get in
my head is what you you talked about
earlier is is the
the inability to to recognize the
potential and so the disbelief of hey if
we do this you know um they could attack
us and kill us all and like nope can't
happen cannot happen and
being unable to acknowledge that if
something isn't the way you think that
it is and someone going i guess i gotta
think someone's going hey boss do you
think we should bring it inside the
lines because it could create some
potential risk for us
and the answer is
that can't happen or some i'm trying to
create in my mind some version of that
where the disbelief is so high that they
don't even recognize
i can't come up with another way to
understand how it could be so bad other
than when you made that connection of
detachment and how do you deal with with
information that you can't process you
just deny that it happened
how old is your oldest daughter 12. okay
so if i
said your oldest daughter and what type
of military training is she had
a little bit you know what i'm saying
like you take a 12 year old girl
that plays guitar and is on the freaking
um softball team whatever yeah
and you say hey listen i want you to
design a fort to defend yourself from
bad guys
here's what you have here's the supplies
that you have there's zero chance zero
chance that your daughter says you know
what here's where we're gonna put all of
our guns and all of our army and we're
gonna put our supplies way over here
there's no chance that that happens
it's freaking ridiculous
the the power of the psychology of of
disbelief or whatever i'm coming up with
the term of you say something i'm like
that can't be possible so i so my only
choice is to dismiss it yeah and again
the detachment piece
if you sit there and come up with a plan
yourself you're not going to see these
things you gotta even if you have even
if you have to let your 12 year old
daughter come up with a plan but dude is
it is it so unreasonable for me to just
say hey man can you at least put your
supplies inside the lines
from a professional military i have no
idea why that decision was made doesn't
really talk about it you know is it like
hey
well i mean i can't even really think of
a reason right now right um hey we don't
want the
stores to be
attracting bears i mean i don't know
unless
like
that's why you might not stay with your
food if you're in alaska right
um i don't know what they're thinking
it's cr it's craziness
but
if you're all wrapped up in it
you can't you're not going to see it
yeah i guess the other end that you
might not see is if you're too far away
from it if you're the boss and you're
like hey just go ahead and put the
storage wherever you want and you know
you're like well you know i want this to
look like an organized camp so i don't
want a bunch of crap sitting around here
so we're going to move it out there and
i don't pay attention to it yeah so
maybe there's too much detachment my
guess is not enough well i mean i think
there's some validity to that comment
though it's certain elements throughout
this you're talking about people that
are so far detached they're they're
miles so they're so far away that
there's not even a connection to the
potential risks that come from that so i
think you're right i think there is
elements of this is like
i don't the the boss doesn't doesn't
doesn't seem to care about these
critical fundamental things because he
is like oh i got to make sure
my personal gear gets across this river
it's taking him 28 hours this guy is so
detached from things while he's
so focused in on these other things yup
yup and there's a dichotomy for sure
oddly enough
uh the government of india chose this
moment to appoint major general
william george keith
elfinstone as commander-in-chief in
afghanistan
he was to say the least an unfortunate
candidate described at the time as quote
the most incompetent soldier that was to
be found among the officers of requisite
rank
and it sucks because we're laughing and
you're going to see what happens and
it's freaking heinous even if necessary
his qualifications were certainly not
sufficient
they were they were that he was quote of
good repute
gentlemanly manners and aristocratic
connections so that's why he's getting
hired he's good repute he's gentlemanly
manners and the aristocratic connections
this is like the opposite of the of the
uh btf tony in case of war break glass
like hey i gotta go we gotta scrap you
want me to go you only take a bunch of
people and live out in the middle of you
know bad guy country
this is not i don't want anyone
genuinely manners i want somebody with
that knows how to throw a hatchet
yeah do i want that nice guy who's well
connected no no i don't want that guy
he had last seen active service at
waterloo 25 years previously and had
since been on half pay he was elderly
and so stricken with gout that he could
scarcely move
like general sir redverse buller half a
century later
elfin stone had no illusion about his
unfitness for the job and he pleaded
that his health made him quite unsuited
to the demands that would be put upon
him but lord auckland the governor
general was adamant and so the gentle
courteous elfin stone was shipped off to
kabul once there whatever shreds of
self-confidence he may have had were
speedily removed firstly by the
ludicrous nature of the army's uh
contonent
and secondly by encountering for the
first time his new second in command
brigadier shelton a rough brute of
uncertain temper
so appalled was elfinstone by the army's
location that he offered to buy up
surrounding land so he could
then clear the suitable fields of fire
his generous offer was refused
about shelton he could do nothing so he
kind of showed up and recognized they're
in a bad spot
um fast forward a little bit
there's a there's another area and he
goes
trying to figure these things out elf
and stone ordered shelton to march on
the fortress this is their another area
no sooner had this order been received
though that it was countermanded sheldon
unimpressed by this stop go policy
reported retorted that
retorted sharply that if there was an
insurrection in the city
it was not a moment for indecision and
recommended
that elf and stone at once decide upon
what measure we should adopt elphinstone
then countermanded his countermand
and once more ordered shelton to march
at once to balahasar that's an area
where they were having issues
but barely had shelton started before he
was overtaken by another order to the
effect that he should halt and remain
where he was but no sooner had this
order been received reducing the second
in command to a state of approaching
epilepsy that it was followed by the
inevitable counter-order it seemed that
he was after all to proceed with his men
to the fort and this surprisingly he did
meanwhile elphinstone was canvassing
opinions as to what to do next i mean
this is just a freaking disaster when
elfinstone eve did act when eventually
elfinstone did act it was a case of too
little too late
mcnaughton a brave there's a guy that
tries to sort of
figure out and negotiate a deal a guy
named mcnaughton
and says mcnaughton a braver man the
nelson stone tried to double cross the
afghans and was murdered for his pains
and there's another uh like british
british uh
civil servant that gets murdered
fast forward a little bit more again we
get these books so you can understand
these a little bit more fully
while rage and a thirst for revenge
consumed the lower ranks of the army
those at the top became increasingly
indecisive and anxious to appease
inevitable inevitably the afghan
surrender terms stiffened until finally
elphinstone in response to empty
promises of safe conduct found himself
agreeing that his army
without its ordinance but encumbered by
twelve thousand non-combatants including
many women and children would go back
the way they had come
so they decided to give up arms this may
sound familiar to everyone right now
they're in afghanistan they decide oh if
you let us out of here we'll give up our
arms and and when we go to give up our
arms that's okay but we also have a
bunch of our wives and children with us
i don't know if i made that clear yet
this is the old school
you know imperial idea you go on
deployment you're going to go for years
you're going to take your wife and
family with you
having decided upon the disastrous plan
of trying to reach
jalalabad in the depths of winter across
mountain ranges infested with hostile
tribesmen elfinstone proceeded to make
matters worse by further procrastination
right up to january 6 1842 he remained
in agony of mind as to whether or not he
should commit any commit his army to the
march and when on that fateful day they
eventually set off he changed his mind
when half the force were already on
their way like you can't make this up
like if i told you that this guy was
changing his mind every 20 minutes or
every day you just wouldn't believe me
it doesn't sound real
he tried to stop them but now
his order to halt was disobeyed
for good or ill the die was cast it was
for real
so here's this group
walking unarmed through afghanistan
again this may sound familiar they walk
here we go without food firewood or or
any shelter beyond that provided by
holes scraped in the snow many died each
night
by day as they traversed grim passes
thousands more died at the hands of
murderous gil's eyes which is a pashtun
tribe like hill people
at the end of four days with 70 miles
still to go only 850 remained of the
original 4 500 soldiers by the end of
the tenth day their number had been
reduced to 450. throughout this pitiful
adventure elphinstone despite the trail
of corpses which lay behind him retained
a pathetic and wholly unjustified faith
in the afghan leader's promise of safe
conduct
hmm
by the end of the fifth day the total
losses of soldiers and civilians had
risen to twelve thousand as one officer
described it this was there was
literally a continuous lane of poor
wretches of men women and children dead
and dying from the cold or wounds
unable to move and treated their
comrades to kill them to put an end to
their misery
i mean it's just it's it's horrible how
did this on how did this unfold here's
alpha stones this refined and gentle
creature manifested what at first sight
may appear to be some curiously
inconsistent characteristics by his own
admission he sought the bubble
reputation in india and yet when given
important command shrank from the
responsibilities it entailed he was
hopelessly indecisive lacking in moral
courage and
suggestible yet could on occasions
manifest irrational pig-headedness he
wobbled when he should have been firm
yet was rigid when he should have been
flexible what a nightmare that is
finally he was courteous and kind
retaining the affection of many of his
followers right up to the end yet could
be totally lacking in compassion for
many of those who had suffered at his
hands
this is a thing to watch out for by the
way
people that are super nice
and get along really well with everybody
but they make bad decisions a lot and
people just kind of like can't get mad
at them
just just to wrap this section up to
conclude this account of the total
dissolution of an army on january 13
1842 soldiers on guard at the british
fort in jalalabad saw a single horseman
riding toward them with all the speed
that his maimed and worn out horse could
muster it was the surgeon dr briden
the only man it seemed to survive the
fearful journey from kabul
and the footnote here is that bride was
the only european to arrive at jalalabad
but in the days after his arrival a few
indian soldiers and a number of
followers also completed the journey
elphinstone himself died of dysentery
after being made captive of akbar khan
we were laughing a couple minutes ago
and i don't know i wish i could remember
the word there's a word that described
like when your reaction doesn't actually
match what you're feeling and i forgot
what that word is but it it's
it's a it's a the level of disbelief i
mean this the reaction that i'm having
you're hearing this when you're laughing
at the description
comes from like the level of tragedy
that this is
the
this is a lot because i didn't read this
you know i had actually i have this book
i mean i knew i kind of knew this was
coming but i didn't do the what you did
i didn't do this cover to cover depth i
kind of spun around and you had shared
some things with me the depth of here is
much more than i kind of anticipated
and
you still have for me it's still this
hard time of connecting the behavior and
the tolerance of the behavior to the
outcome which is real human life
that's the piece and if you look at it
kind of the in the larger
sense of of
of the precursors to world war one it
makes it even that much more difficult
to believe
because if you were gonna give any
potential
free pass
would be
you didn't see this coming if if you
were if you if somehow that could be the
case and so whatever potential nail in
the coffin is left unhit is
you didn't see this coming and this is
just tail upon tail upon tail upon tail
of of of a total disregard
and the hardest part about that is what
you said at the very beginning is
they don't learn any lessons from it yep
and i think that's where the disbelief
for me comes from where i'm i'm laughing
like almost in in literal disbelief of
there's no way this is gonna happen
again
knowing what this all leads up to as
well and let me tell you how easy this
is
how easy this is
and this is what's so freaking crazy you
and i look at a situation like this and
we go uh there's one thing wrong bad
leadership
bad leadership oh you got a problem like
that it's bad leadership did they pick a
bad spot why they pick a bad spot
because they got bad leadership like
this is just bad leadership bad
leadership bad leaders are bad
leadership so at some point you look at
these disasters
and you say hey
our freaking leadership selection
training
is wrong we're doing something wrong we
need to fix it
instead what do they do they blame the
troops they blame the weather they blame
the enemy that's what they do
and that's accepted up and down the
chain of command
it's a freaking disaster it's crazy
and this was look i i you we'd have a
bad seal platoon coming through
zero times
zero times did i say wow the troops are
all jacked up wow the e5s don't know how
to work the machine guns wow the
freaking uh the the corpsman doesn't
know how to work on people the the point
man doesn't know how to
navigate
zero times did i say that now would you
have a bad freak appointment
occasionally that would get lost yeah
and you know what good leadership would
say hey dude you're going to real
security right now you know we'll work
on your did you have somebody that was
maybe not too great on a machine gun
what'd they do the leadership said hey
bro you need to go out and do some extra
machine gun classes and courses you need
to run some drills so you're better
never did i say well you know this
platoon is gonna fail this block of
training because they're machine gunners
because they're riflemen
because of any other reason then the
freaking leader is jacked up totally
that's what's going on and either the
leader figures it out or you got to
replace him and that's a hundred percent
of the time that's a hundred percent of
that because if you're even if in a
fantasy world you had a platoon come in
where all the machine gunners were
terrible all the people were fat and out
of shape
all of that you could be traced back to
oh
is there is there genetic makeup in this
this seal platoon somehow different than
all their owns or is there actually a
leader who for the last 18 months
has been tolerating or not holding a
center or not training or not what has
allowed this to happen first of all we
know it doesn't happen but even if it
did is there something unique about
those people that doesn't allow them to
operate a machine gun or is there a
leader tolerating this behavior to let
that place to get to a state that's so
bad that they're incompetent and again
i'm even saying that just
just to reinforce the idea
that we know that it happened zero
percent of the time but even if it did
in a fantasy world it still comes back
to the exact same reason why there's a
leader allowing that to happen at some
point in my career probably when i read
about face for the 19th time and he
talks about the fact that there's no bad
teams only bad leaders
that that changed my perspective for the
rest of my life
because you look at a jacked up
organization a platoon a task unit a
team a battalion a company a business
you look at it and you see problems you
go oh it's oh i already know what the
problem is
i already know what the problem is
and yet as to your point
despite these failures in india in
afghanistan in crimea in
the boomer wars in south africa despite
all these failures
failure upon failure upon failure upon
failure which is
freaking
a red flashing light when you look at it
with hindsight and you go it's
leadership leadership leadership
leadership and yet
you're gonna see they're not they're not
even developing their leaders properly
they don't make any changes
and by the way let me throw this out
there i've worked with the brits the
freaking brits are outstanding totally
the brits are freaking outstanding
soldiers they're some of the most
professional
human beings never even mind military
they're some of the most professional
human beings i've ever interacted with
in my life
so
obviously now they've made some steps
but
and just just another thought i keep
having and this came up for me we talked
about it during war as a racket 300
that
is is
is
these are hard stories to listen to
these are hard stories for me to sit
here as an as an audience member of this
podcast listening to talk about it is to
make sure that
we don't fall into the trap of oh this
is jocko telling a story about a bunch
of other incompetent leaders
the
the ease with which we we can as leaders
especially get put in charge how easy it
is to slide into some of those habits
maybe not to this degree maybe not to
this magnification but this is not a
story to be
to be taken about what's wrong with
everybody else it's how easy a regular
human being can be placed into a
position and fall into the trap of being
a bad leader through things like
humility humility humility humility
detachment
and
that these are tales that that
the lens that you gotta look at is a
mirror as much as anything else they're
like hey do i
do i do some of these things yeah we do
leaders fall into these traps yeah
make yourself that checklist that's
right
am i doing this yeah
all right this brings us to chapter six
which is the first world war
and
here we go only the most blankered could
deny that the first world war
exemplified every aspect of high-level
military incompetence
for sheer lack of imaginative leadership
inept decisions ignoring of military
intelligence underestimation of the
enemy delusional optimism and monumental
wastage of human resources has surely
never had its equal
can you imagine looking at what's
happening and you see all those things
occurring
in an age when it has become fashionable
to question authority it may well seem
strange that a bear 60 years ago
millions of ordinary men
living in
indescribable conditions could with
courage with a courage of fortitude and
cheerfulness past human comprehension
meekly carry out the lethal decisions
of well-fed generals comfortably housed
many miles behind the place where their
orders were being translated into
several kinds of pointless death
apologists for this period have found
good things to say of some jed some of
the generals who took part we are told
that hague
did the best he could given the
conditions of the western front that he
was rock-like and tenacious
joffrey's saving grace so it has been
said was that he was a skilled
politician and the only man with enough
prestige to dominate france's allies
and to quote ajp taylor even sir john
french was supposed for some time to be
a great military leader
other views have been less charitable
quote stupid obstinate blimps butchers
ossified brains and donkeys are just a
few of the unkind epithets which have
been applied to those who bore upon
their immaculate shoulders the
responsibility of committing a
generation of young men to various forms
of mutilation on the battlefield
a contemporary expression of this point
of view puts it thus
it it is hard for a connoisseur of bad
generalship surveying the gray wastes of
world war one to single out any one
commander as especially awful
there were dozens on both sides
incompetence took several forms these
included
the implementation of a plan for the
disposition of the british expeditionary
force that had been devised three years
before the outbreak of hostilities and
remain unmodified in the light of
subsequent events you said this on the
last podcast dave
you're like oh machine gun oh they're
shooting a machine gun at us stop
everyone go back to the planning room
that's how long it takes to figure that
out
we we receive a burst of machine gun
fire and we go hey blow the whistles and
stop and everyone go back to the trench
and we need to figure some out
two
a tenacious clinging to the age-old
practice of frontal assaults usually the
enemy's strongest points
skipping ahead a little bit of three the
under use and misuse of available
technology hague's opinion that two
machine guns per battalion would be
quite sufficient and the attitude of
some reactionary
elements to the development of tank of
the tank are cases in point and we're
going to get into some of that
reactionary
when when people figured out what the
tank was hey i don't know if that's a
good thing it doesn't seem like a good
idea
four a growing belief in the value of
prolonged bombardment before launching
an attack
besides being enormously expensive such
bombardments necessarily sacrificed the
vital element of surprise made the
intervening ground almost impassable to
the subsequent assaulting infantry and
provided numerous convenient craters to
which the enemy machine gunners might be
take themselves from their deep dugouts
after the holocaust was over there to
wait the slowly moving ranks of
attacking infantry
i had to detail that one because as i
read that i was like
why is that bad right oh there's the
reasons
a tendency on the part of high command
to ignore evidence which did not fit in
with their wishes or preconceptions
here's one that you might not anticipate
number six a terrible crippling
obedience
and man if i don't have to go over this
over and over again with people you
don't want subordinates that are just
going to obey
you don't want that
there was even at the highest levels of
command and attitude of mind so
pathological and unrealistic that on
occasions even army commanders dared not
express their doubts about the viability
of a particular order or venture
preferring to conceal evidence from
their superiors rather than be thought
wanting in courage or loyalty
it's better to say yep got it thank you
yes sir we will go and assault that
trench
yes as liedell hart wrote of the third
battle of epres
it would seem that none of the army
commanders ventured to press contrary
views with the strength that the facts
demanded
one of the lessons of the war
exemplified a passchendaele is certainly
the need of allowing more latitude in
the military system for intellectual
honesty and moral courage
there's something very wrong
in your organization if it requires
moral courage to push back against the
boss
right i get it moral courage is
important but if we have an organization
and a culture where you
only push back if you have tremendous
moral courage that's freaking wrong yeah
how much of a mismatch occurs in our
relationship if it requires moral
courage on my my part to ask you a hard
question instead of going hey dude hey
real quick
and you're like yeah what's up yeah how
much how much of a disconnect is there
between you and me if i have to muster
courage and face what is the reason that
i'm being courageous because i'm afraid
i have to deal with this anyway because
there's fear involved what does that say
about a relationship if i'm afraid to
say something
and
you you talked about this ignoring of
evidence and then the the willingness to
just
agree with your leadership how
convenient is it when the the thing you
have to grapple with your own mind is
well i'm not going to be there anyway
i'm not going to be one of the leaders
that gets mowed down so
this isn't nearly as hard for me as it
would be if i'm like whoa hang on i i
have to be out in front of this assault
that's a very different story than i
have to send my men to go do this those
are two very different things yeah they
should be uh it should be worse
it should be worse you should be
thinking hey hold on a second dave hold
on a second sir
i'm not sending my guys i'll go but i'm
not sending my guys it should be the
opposite but it's not and you know
we talked about this a couple times and
and you've referenced or well i mean
it's really point from the book it's
referenced technology
and i made a little connection in my
mind
because a theme that keeps coming
through here is is
uh and i wrote down like disbelief of
the evidence hey the evidence is showing
you this and you're like
i cannot process process i can't process
that so i'm going to just
i'm not going to accept that it's even a
thing there's disbelief in that
i
i saw this when when we developed and
the machine gun was the example we used
last time but when we developed stealth
technology and it really became evident
to the world in desert storm because
nobody really
most people didn't really know what's
going on then all of a sudden firsthand
a desert storm we're flying on the top
of baghdad with airplanes that nobody
could see
and
there was a level of disbelief going on
there from the iraqi defense system as
there's bombs going off around them
they're like i hear i hear airplanes
those are jet engines flying over our
heads i can't see them but i hear them
things are blowing up
but there was an incapacity to to accept
that it was happening because they
didn't see it and this doesn't exist
well
unfortunately one of the byproducts of
that was some people were paying
attention to that and there's this
massive shift from the early 90s to
building style airplanes we have a bunch
of them now guess who else has the
russian the chinese are
you know our primary enemies
but
the idea of being in a fight with
something you can't see
which is what's one of the things that
stealth allows you to do is one of the
most common things that you see when
you're in the stair airplane is other
people behaving as if you're not there
when they know you're there they just
can't see you and like well i'm just
going to keep doing what i'm doing like
good lord
you are just going to allow
things to unfold because you cannot you
cannot come to grips with what is
happening even though
i know it's the wrong choice of words
even though you know it's happening and
that machine gun example is probably the
best real-time example of
there's a machine getting shot at us i
know
but we're just going to keep going down
this path we're going to get to uh
singapore in the second world war and
when singapore goes down the uh
the japanese attack with their aircraft
and it's a night attack and there's like
a 30-minute warning
of hey there's a enemy inbound and a
bunch of the leaders were like no the
japanese don't attack at night
they didn't do anything they didn't
launch aircraft they didn't do anything
they just sat there like oh no that's no
the enemy the japanese don't attack they
don't fly their aircraft at night it's
not them it's not happening it's exactly
what you're saying it's the exact same
thing this isn't happening this isn't
happening this isn't happening yeah
uh detachment from reality
is not good the kind of detachment we
don't like i think it's the one kind of
detachment i don't like it's attachment
from reality and number seven a
readiness to accept enormous casualties
in terms of the number of lives lost
relative to the ground gained the the
actions of the first world war make
dismal reading in the first two hours of
the battle of luz we lost more men than
were last lost by all services together
in the whole of d-day in 1944
that's two hours
on the first day of the psalm
offensive the british army suffered 57
000 casualties on the first day
the biggest loss ever suffered by any
army in a single day and yet as one
historian has put it to see the ground
gained one needs a magnifying glass and
a large scale map
um
the
we he he'll cover some of the world war
one stuff but
it's a pretty brief
as i said in the opening today as he
goes into more well-known events like
world war one he doesn't go into as much
detail because we already know about it
but he does go into some detail this
next chapter is about uh cambray which
there was a battle of cambrian it's
really the first
the first tank
battle where tanks were used
um
and this is just so important because
there's so much resistance here
in 1912 a private civilian inventor e.l
demol of adelaide presented the war
office with the design for a tracked
vehicle which to put it at its simplest
would help solve the major tactical
problem of the first world war which
hadn't even started yet how to get
soldiers across no man land barbed wire
and enemy trenches without being shot
the war office looked at demol's design
and laid it on its on one side in 1915
through a total lack of personal
protection british soldiers on the
western front were dying at the rate of
thousands a day demol was moved to
resubmit his invention
again it was ignored
and by the way he didn't come up with
this idea forerunners of the tank can be
traced back to caesar's invasion of
britain leonardo da vinci had designed
an armored fighting vehicle in the 16th
century and the concept was advanced by
h.g wells in his book the lion iron
clads published in 1903.
i remember when i was a kid i saw that
leonardo da vinci tank i was pretty
stoked on that thing
it might be concluded therefore that his
invention was put aside not just because
it was a new idea which it was not nor
because it was not needed which it was
but because it conflicted with a
mystical belief in the virtues of horsed
cavalry and in the power of a prolonged
military barrage
now we get into some of the politics
that was going on
about the tanks while churchill and
lloyd
george were enthusiastic supporters of
the tanks
master general of ordinance general von
danop remained implicitly implacably
opposed to any such development in the
services the major proponents of the
tank development included ironically a
small group of naval officers
the fact that the admiralty felt less
quote threatened by tanks than the war
office did was strikingly illustrated at
one of those demonstrations wherein
proponents of a new idea
strive to convert skeptics by
confrontation with evidence of their
senses
after an impeccable display in which
prototype tanks cut through barbed wire
cross
trenches slithered through mud and
clawed their way out of craters a naval
officer was heard to remark we ought to
order 3000 now so the navy guy's like
hey bro that looks like a pretty
freaking good thing
but the war office contingent remained
cool one senior general recording who is
this damn naval man saying we will want
3 000 tanks he talks like napoleon
him in his detached point of view
um
[Music]
they get some tanks they get some of
them they use them in battle
and and here's what happens of course
how do they use them about this is like
when you learn a new jiu jitsu move
like hey echo you know here's this new
move and i teach you the freaking
whatever
some arm lock variation
you go try it for the first time how
does it work
it doesn't work yeah so you're like i'm
never using this again
similar
activities here
the small cooper
cooper writes the small part played by
the tanks however successful on the
local scale was overlooked in the
general sense of failure doubts which
many staff officers had previously
expressed as expressed as the value of
tanks turned to scorn instead of trying
to plan an intelligent use of the
superior weapon that had been put in
their hands the military leaders could
only make minor criticisms of minor
details you joke loose arm lock i was
totally off balance you know whatever
instead of you saying hey you know i
need to make some adjustments the way
i'm employing this can you help me
instead you just go dude i'm not your
move sucks
don't you yeah i mean you always say how
when you implement anything new yeah
you're going to lose efficiency or lose
efficiency yeah the first thing that
happens you become less that happens all
the time to me in jiu jitsu some new
move that i'm starting to work i get
smashed by everyone oh yeah and you're
even it jams up other parts of yours
because you're thinking way more way
less than than you usually would
and then yeah just be like oh yeah jiu
jitsu sucks now yeah or that yeah that
move messed up my game that whole game
that whole part of my game is i'm not
not doing that anymore
fast forward a little bit frustrated by
failure and unable to admit their own
contributions to defeat by the way when
they lost this battle when they used
tanks for the first time what was the
problem oh it was the tanks there wasn't
anything that any mistake that they made
they did what all what the highly
prejudiced do in such a circumstance
vented their feelings upon the original
object of their prejudice and in doing
so precluded any chance of learning from
the exercise
fast forward a little bit meanwhile the
futile
third battle of eapres continued to
consume the lives of intramu infantrymen
at the rate of more than 2 000 a day
nevertheless the general headquarters
blamed the waste of life upon the few
tanks that had been used i mean this is
freaky you can't make this up it
seems they
they just disappeared into the mud along
with everything else
now here we get to this chapter's thing
the cambrai
cambrai
tank offensive on november 20th 1917
occurred in three stages the first was
eminently successful 380 tanks operating
on ground suited to caterpillar tracks
achieved a spectacular success over
running three strongly held lines of
enemy trenches whereas previous offenses
had been lost measured in yards gained
for tens of thousands of lives lost the
cambray offense advance was four and a
half miles on a six mile front with
negligible casualties so there you go
they freaking use the tank they're like
hell yeah this worked
but if the first phase
first stage was an unprecedented victory
the second showed a beginning of the rot
which was to turn victory into disaster
there were various contributory factors
the first was general harper whose 51st
highland division had been given the
task of capturing key objectives in the
center of the attack the village of
fleskires
i'm sorry everybody about my
pronunciation
unfortunately harper
who had been described as a quote a
narrow-minded soldier of the old school
was one of those who disapproved of
tanks consequently not only were his
troops given little training in working
with the new weapon but they were
instructed in tactics contrary to those
recommended by the tank core even worse
harper delayed his assault by one hour
because he did not believe that the
first objective the hindenburg main line
would be captured so quickly so this
guy's just a hater
out of the gate
can you imagine you get a tank and
you're like hey i'm not going to give my
people proper training on it
the unnecessary delay allowed the
germans in an hour
allowed the germans an hour in which to
bring up and sight field guns on the
ridge here in one here's one description
of what followed the tanks continued
blightly onto the crest of the ridge in
line abreast as instructed they came to
the top huge dark shapes silhouetted
against the skyline
and there before them were the german
field guns had the infantry been close
behind the tanks as fuller had planned
they could have easily dealt with these
guns in a matter of minutes but the
infantry were far behind not only held
up by having to find their way through
the wire but because of the machine gun
fire which was causing heavy casualties
the tanks were on their own with such
perfect targets the german gunners
opened fire one by one the tanks were
hit while the crews worked desperately
at the cumbersome gears to drive a
zigzag course and the gunners tried to
return fire but taking accurate aim and
all the pitching and tossing was
virtually impossible it was some minutes
before the german guns had been put out
of action but by this time 16 tanks had
been destroyed with huge gaping holes in
their sides most were on fire and those
crew members who had not been killed
outright by the blasting shells were
burned to death
there were no survivors
through a pious fast forward through a
pious and mistaken belief in the value
of horsed cavalry and a paralysis
thought occasioned by years of trench
warfare the brilliant breakthrough by
the tanks was thrown away some 10 days
later the germans counter-attacked in a
matter of hours they recovered much of
the ground originally lost the british
third army commanded by general sir
julian bing
lost 6 000 men taken prisoner some
thousands killed or wounded and a vast
quantity of guns and other equipment
the magnitude of this
disaster was directly attributable to a
feature of high level military
incompetence seen all too often the
ignoring of intelligence reports which
did not fit in with the preconceived
ideas when at last news of the disaster
reached britain it was naturally assumed
that the generals had failed again
hague's reputation already low sank to a
vanishing point the war cabinet demanded
an immediate explanation
hague's response was to endorse a report
from general bing that the third army
had not been taken by surprise and that
the failure to stem the german
breakthrough was due to the shortcomings
of those junior officers ncos and men
who had been involved in the fighting
what a freaking savage
in the face of so much contrary evidence
these views did not impress the critics
to stifle further debate the war cabinet
called in general smuts
and this freaking savage
smut stated and they go into what his
relationships are and he's you know he's
just a just a real piece of smut
stated higher command army or core
command were not to blame everything had
been done to meet such an attack he went
on to say that the fault lay either with
local commanders who might have lost
their heads or with those lower down
junior officers ntos and men of those
two alternatives he preferred the latter
explanation and so smuts in the fashion
of the day blame those least able to
answer back the youthful the junior and
the dead
again what corrections are we now making
we're not making any corrections we're
just like oh yeah it's the team's fault
and by the way the team who fought with
bravery that
is unquestionable
all in all this black episode raises
several matters of great rel
relevance to the theory of military
incompetence presented later in this
book stupidity does not explain the
behavior of these generals
so great was their fear
of loss of self-esteem and so imperative
their need for social approval approval
that they could resort to tactics beyond
the reach of any self-respecting donkey
from their shameless self-interest lack
of loyalty to their subordinates and
apparent indifference to the verdict of
posterity a picture emerges of
personalities deficient in something
other than intel intellectual acumen
so again these people aren't stupid
how about that phrase a lack of loyalty
to your subordinates
and how often we fall into the idea like
that's supposed to work the opposite
direction they should be loyal to me
because i'm in charge i'm the commander
and it's the lack of loyalty to your
subordinates
as the cause of why this happens
sickening
as to how they look to a contemporary
chronicler here is the following passage
and so the white washing went on
to protect armchair generals who in the
main had little conception of what the
front line was like and had no intention
of going there to find out one of those
infantrymen so blamed was j.h everest
during the two days when he and his
fellow soldiers were being pushed back
by the germans they had no water to
drink and no food to eat at the end of
the second day while waiting in a trench
for a renewed attack everest went up to
his company commander and asked for
permission to search for water
my request was refused everest wrote in
a letter nonetheless i went over the top
and found some water in a mud hole thus
ending two days of torture
shortly afterwards everest was wounded
and found himself in the australian
general hospital at abbeville
but the most bitter pill on top of this
was to be blamed for their commander's
own mistakes
can you imagine reading those freaking
articles
about how jacked up you were
another world war one
example here chapter eight the siege of
cut
if the degree of military incompetence
is indicated by the ratio of achievement
to cost
then the activities of expedite
expeditionary force d under the command
of major general sir charles townsend
merit examination
firstly there was a 250 mile discrepancy
between what was designed to do and what
it tried to do secondly the cost of the
this discrepancy was large to reach cut
cost townsend seven thousand casualties
during the ensuing siege a further 1600
died attempts to relieve his force
accounted for another 23 000 casualties
when he eventually surrendered to the
turks thirteen thousand of his troops
went into captivity and seven thousand
of these died while still prisoners of
war
all of us went for nothing not one inch
of ground or any political advantage
nothing that is beyond corpses suffering
and ruined reputation so you have this
this
take place
this is in iraq
in mesopotamia
i mean this is i guess current day iraq
and mesopotamia there were four enemies
the turkish army
marauding arabs the terrain and the
climate all four played their part in
hazarding the lines of communication and
bringing about a defeat which cost much
and gained nothing but the real
instigators of this tragedy were neither
the climate nor geography neither the
turks nor the arabs but three generals
general beauchamp duff
commander in chief india general nixon
army commander basra and major general
townsend commander of the sixth division
through an admixture of self-interest
personal ambition ignorance obstinacy
and sheer crash stupidity this trio
sealed the fate of some thousands of
british in and indian soldiers
i kind of wanted to fast forward through
this part but
this one is insane
nixon who made up an ambition for what
he lacked for in intelligence ordered
townsend to capture amara a township on
the tigris some hundred miles north of
basra townsend equally ambitious but by
no means stupid did as
as he was bit in doing so he and nixon
were already exceeding the directive of
the british government
so they're kind of pushing the envelope
down there
a little glory seeking happening as well
as occupying amara
townsend struck westward and took
nazaria
nixon's appetite for glory was wedded by
these easy victories with no thought to
the risks involved he pressed townsend
to continue his advance a further 90
miles to cut
in this he was backed by duff who had
never visited mesopotamia
and had no idea of the conditions
prevailing there but townsend had
he wrote to general sir james wolfe
murray in england
by the way townsend is about to become a
villain
of horror that you've
likely can't even understand
i believe this is this so this is
townsend running back i believe i am too
advanced to amara to cut to el amara the
question is where are we going to stop
in mesopotamia so i this sounds good
right okay wait a second dude
what are we trying to do we certainly
have not
good enough troops to make certain of
taking bad dad baghdad
of our two divisions mine the sixth is
complete
the twelfth has no guns
or divisional troops and nixon takes
them from me and lends them to guardians
when he has to go anywhere i consider we
ought to hold on to what we've got as
long as we are held up as we are in the
dardanelles
all these offensive operations in
secondary theaters are dreadful errors
in strategy the dardanelles egypt
mesopotamia east africa i wonder and
wonder at such expeditions being
permitted in violation of all great
fundamental principles of war especially
that of economy of force such as a
violation is always punished in history
so he's saying you gotta prioritize and
execute why are we running around doing
all these different things
i'm afraid we are out in the cold here
the mesopotamian operations are a little
noticed
though we are fighting the same enemy as
you have in the dardanelles plus an
appalling heat the hardship in france
are nothing to that
so this seems like a logical thing right
townsend's like hey dude what are we
doing like we already kind of got done
what we're supposed to get done why are
we pushing further let's hold what we
got i don't have a bunch of troops i'm
getting my my troops are getting pulled
all over the place let's just kind of
stand down
but it's an interesting um
there's another historian that writes
the letter was completely in character
it revealed a gift for strategic
appreciation amounting to
uh prescience
it revealed townsend's chronic tendency
to criticize his superiors and his
obsession with his own affairs to the
exclusion of all others it revealed his
habitual lack of general of generosity
to his colleagues who whom he praised
only if they were of inferior rank to
himself his tendency to whine and almost
embarrassing immodesty
i think that's a hard reading of that
letter i think that's a little bit
strong
but the most extraordinary feature in
the letter was that for all its
strategic prescience it bore little
relationship to towns and subsequent
behavior i guess that's what makes it
interesting though he clearly realized
that he was being asked to undertake a
major campaign with the logistics of a
subsidiary defensive operation he said
nothing of this to his superiors 17 days
after writing to murray townsend not
only enthusiastically accepted nixon's
orders that he should advance a further
90 miles to cut but also
entirely of his own bat
talked of pursuing the enemy another 190
miles and possibly beyond that to
baghdad
indisputably he was a man ambitious to
the point of egomania a man whom the
lore of promotion had goaded throughout
his career to such an incessant
intriguing and important lighter writing
that he'd incurred constant snubbing and
rebuke yet he had persisted
to such a man the smallest hint of
condemnation seems enthusiastic
improvable
closing his mind to to his own
forebodings townsend and his
unsuspecting troops pressed on once
again the turks were defeated and the
british occupied cut so they do they
press into cut um but this battle is not
easy because remember i said those
earlier battles were kind of easy at cut
it's not easy
and
it's not easy for townsend's troops it's
not easy for
the the turks either
he says about the turks the turks though
suffering many casualties they were not
destroyed they escaped
and then there were the british wounds
here's what's going on with the british
wounded the wounded suffered frightfully
untended they lay freezing all night
some to be stripped and murdered by
arabs and when daylight came were placed
on supply carts unsprung iron slatted
and drawn across a cruelly uneven
surface to the riverbank there in fierce
sun they languished until they could be
crammed onto decks of iron barges and
towed very slowly downstream to omura
what little water they were given was
impure what little treatment they could
be given was ineffective their wounds
went gangrene
and they lay in a morass of their own
blood and ex
and excreta
assailed by millions of flies quite
unnecessarily many of them died
um
now townsend they also say this for
another he was despite his appraisal of
realities loath to relinquish his own
dream of becoming lieutenant general
cyril townsend lord of baghdad
and so grossly unequipped he marched his
men beyond the point of no return
towards baghdad he never reached that
fabled city
for a army of 13 000 turks lay across
his path
nixon received nixon received
intelligence that a second turkish army
thirty thousand strong
and led by the redoubtable khalil pasha
was also converging
but because this news did not accord
with his desires nixon chose to ignore
the report is untrue
thirty thousand people heading to take
on your
whatever you have 12 000.
the battle marked the end of townsend's
luck through his conduct though his
conduct of the fight was exemplary if
not brilliant he sustained 4 000
casualties and again did not succeed in
routing or destroying the enemy
he withdrew his force to cut
cut which he knew
to be without defense so
this this town of cut is not like a
really great defensive position and
townsend knows it
townsend's newfound delusion regarding
the virtues of cut may well have had its
origins in a much earlier event
the siege of chitral
when intractable desires are thwarted by
reality there is a tendency to hark back
to the memory of early earlier
gratifications and chatrol epitomized
for townsend just such gratification
here so this is townsend as a young
officer of the indian army he had
withdrawn into a fort and
and captained his small force throughout
46 days of siege when eventually he did
emerge it was to find himself a hero
beloved by queen and country so that's
what happened to him as a young officer
he goes into this place they learn in
lock down and they hold out for 46 days
so now he's going to do the same thing
at cut that's his plan
he can now overlook the shortcomings of
cut
and see in his smelly collection of mud
huts the key to ultimate success
um another inconsistency in townsend's
behavior is that he had always prided
himself upon the fact that he drew upon
the lessons of history identifying
himself as the occasion demanded with
such great captains as hannibal napoleon
and wellington
but we joke about that when you think
you're freaking wellington or hannibal
or napoleon there was nothing he liked
better than to quote the precepts of
famous military commanders two such
precepts were to make wars to attack and
movement is the law of strategy but here
was townsend's townsend as heedless of
fred frederick the great as he was deaf
to the council of martial falk
for the bottle himself up in cut was to
assume a posture of defense as
stationary as it was passive so why is
he doing this
well he's doing it because he remembers
that he had the big victory back in the
day
and it was unnecessary for there was
still time to fall back on the safety of
our so he could have still made it out
of there
that he did not do so cannot be ascribed
to stupidity or to ignorance of the
principles of war for townsend was
neither stupid nor ignorant his first
move toward hastening his rescue was so
was so to manipulate his would-be
rescuers so they felt compelled to try
and relieve the siege before they were
ready thus he persuaded his army
commander at basra that since he had
only a month's supply of food for his
british troops and early relief was
essential to sustain this lie and force
nixon's hand he deliberately refrained
from rationing either as british or
indian troops nor did he make any
attempt to unearth the stocks of arab
grain concealed within the town so he's
out of the gate he's just telling mize
hey you better come and rest me first
i'm running out of food just a freaking
lie
what does nixon do well nixon's
trying to help out okay dude i want my
people to starve nixon ordered the
unfortunate lieutenant general
ailmer
to break through the turkish defense
forces and relief cut
there's a whole section on here talking
about how that goes down elmer failed
time and time again to achieve the
impossible thanks to the combined
efforts of the man he was trying to
rescue and those of nixon the man
largely the man largely responsible for
rescue being necessary the relief force
suffered 23 000 casualties nearly twice
the number of those invested
so this guy tells lies they're like hey
we need to go help him we're not ready
yet but just run in there anyways and
they take freaking 23 000 casualties
more than these trying to save 12 yeah
double the people that are in there
remember
i think it was a debrief podcast we
talked about you talked about you made a
list of things that keep you from being
successful in the future and one of them
was lessons learned yeah you always
liked that one i did because it was
something i didn't expect
the way and not just the way you were
going through the list because the list
was like obvious ones or or let me say
that more carefully what appeared to be
obvious ones
and you got to that and
it's so easy now once i've heard you say
it to just transpose that idea of
lessons learned actually if you're
and you didn't say don't take lessons
learned of course not but they can be
an impediment especially if like
the paradigm or the or the the scenario
with which that lesson was learned
doesn't actually apply to the scenario
that you're in but it's the same city
well it must be the same situation cool
we'll just take that and we'll just i
did this back in the day when i was 23
and i was a hero
watch this
and of course it's easy to see now
because i'm sitting in a detached
position but
you i
did you wrote down i wrote down you said
it
delusion
disbelief
and
desire god bless he's hearing that good
lord how bad and if that third one might
be the worst one of like i want to be a
hero
i want to be what did he call himself
the king of baghdad or
whatever whatever yeah that desire and
go we're losing no we're not hey we're
outnumbered no we're not hey we
shouldn't do this yes we should because
you know what i want i want to be the
king of baghdad
freaking disturbing crazy man the um the
thing about lessons learned
lessons learned should open your mind
not close your mind
uh these guys are lying by the way
secretary of state for indian army
commander basra joseph chamberlain
cabled this statement on arrival wounded
on arrival wounded basra please
telegraph urgently particulars and
progress so this guy's saying hey what's
going on with the wounded you got
and nixon replies wounded satisfactorily
disposed of many likely to recover
medical services under circumstances of
considerable difficulty worked
splendidly
but nixon two had lied for you just
witnessed the arrival of 4 000.
and the the
mejide which is a ship with 600
casualties on board and two crammed
lighters in tow
had reached basra festooned with
with stala tight salicites of extra
excreta
and exuding a stench that was offensive
from a distance of 100 yards she had
labored downstream for 13 days and
nights on her decks and on the exposed
decks of her lighters men lay huddled in
pools of blood urine and feces their
bodies slimed with excrement their
wounds crawling with maggots their
shattered bones splinted in wood from
whiskey crates and the handles of
trenching tools and their thighs backs
and buttocks leprous with sores
and meanwhile townsend he's got his guys
safely up and cut well all this is
happening these guys are getting
slaughtered 23 000 casualties
and townsend's up there kind of chilling
over the period of the siege he had he
evinced several characteristics
his townsend's communications were not
however confined to those outside cut
during the siege he had devoted much
attention to issuing of communiques to
his troops these were remarkable for
three features a flagrant disloyalty
toward
towards and criticism of his superiors
of thinly veiled contempt for the
valiant but unsuccessful relief force
and a total absence of gratitude toward
those who were losing their lives trying
to rescue him
townsend was always prepared to abandon
his beloved command in the interest of
either his own release or his own
advancement on march 5th he had again
requested promotion
this guy's calling he's capped he's
freaking
in sieged
after causing himself to be there he's
asking to get promoted on april 9th for
the second time he had suggested that he
should attempt escape to escape from cut
and leave his division to its fate
can you imagine running that up the
chain of command hey boss
i'm good i think i should just try and
get out of here and whatever happens the
division kind of happens the division
three times he had suggested negotiation
to exchange cut and its guns for the
release of himself and his men though he
must have known that only he would be
allowed to go twice he had sent
ingratiating letters to the enemy
commander in the field and once had
insisted that no attempt be made on the
life of an enemy field marshal
any doubts to the correct interpretation
of these unedifying facts are dispelled
by three subsequent events the first is
a minor one but nonetheless revealing
when townsend learned that that ale
mayor's successor gringe had been
promoted to lieutenant general he burst
into tears and wept on the shoulder of a
shrinking subaltern because he knew that
gringe's promotion meant none for him
the second is the fact
that he did leave his division to die as
prisoners of the turks and the third is
that neither then nor later did he so
much as lift a finger to ameliorate
their plight
for present purposes little remains to
be said after 147 days townsend's food
supplies which he'd originally stated
would only last a month ran out
confident from his exchange with the
turkish commander that he would be
treated generously he capitulated on
april 19 1916 and handed his weak
starving men over to the not-so-tender
mercy of the turks
then it was where their paths diverged
while he was transported in the greatest
comfort to baghdad and thenced against
constantinople his thirteen thousand men
began their one thousand two hundred
mile march across the arid waste and
freezing heights of asia minor and while
he was wined and dined honored and
entertained as the personal guest of the
turkish commander-in-chief his men died
in their thousands of starvation
dysentery cholera and typhus and from
the whips of their bad-tempered
kurdistan guards
they died of the heat by day and of cold
by night they died because they wearied
of staying alive dropping out of the
column to be set upon by marauding arabs
who have robbed them filled their mouths
with sand and stones
in all seventy percent of the british
and fifty percent of the indian troops
perished in captivity
but townsend was spared these sword
details
for he traveled by train and arrived at
constantinople on june 3 was met by the
general commander of the turkish army
his staff members of the war office and
a crowd of respectful locals he felt
very flattered he was even more
flattered to be entertained later at
constantinople's best restaurant then
escorted by a detachment of cavalry to
the waterfront where a naval penis
waited him
his baggage staff and servants aboard he
sailed 10 miles down the sea of
marmara to the fashionable island of
halki where high on a cliff he took up
residence in a comfortable villa that
same day in the building the turks
called the hospital those of townsen's
troops still too ill to march from
samara were being allowed by their
captors to die in agony
there was no treatment for them and very
little food and those who fouled their
beds were given an injection of brandly
colored fluid after which they stopped
fouling their beds because they were
dead
by that same day
more than a third of the british troops
to whom townsend had vowed he was
leaving them only to procure their
reparation
had died
yeah i don't know if it gets any worse
than that
back to the point of this book in
conclusion one point demands particular
emphasis
in the mismanagement of the mesopotamian
campaign sheer stupidity played a
relatively minor role certainly duff was
no genius and nixon was unintelligent
but townsend was not
men's fates were decided for them not so
much by idiots as by commanders with
marked psychopathic traits
stupidity and ignorance there may have
been
but it was the ambitious striving of
disturbed personalities which accounted
for the loss of townsend's force
in such matters as vanity personal
ambition dishonesty
lack of
lack of compassion townsend was not
unique
where he differed from others was in
possessing charm intelligence and
professional expertise
in a world of the square the pompous and
the desperately unfunny townsend had a
refreshingly light touch
but underneath the agreeable veneer
there lay a fatal flaw which showed
itself in ravenous self-destructive
hunger for popular acclaim
though its origins remain obscure
townsend gave the impression of a man
who at some time had suffered traumatic
damage to his self-esteem which resulted
in an everlasting need
[Music]
to be loved
well
that kind of wraps up the world war one
phase
[Music]
but there you go you got a smart man
a charismatic man a guy with combat
experience and a guy with psychopathic
traits
if you take those first one smart man
charismatic man
right
that guy would breeze through
uh officer so you know if we're looking
for an offspring this guy's very
charismatic he's very intelligent right
oh let's sign him up let's put him in
charge of something
and not only do we bring him in
but then he's going to rise through the
ranks because he's charming and he's
smart right and he's
he he
as things go well
when things are going well he's freaking
fantastic
but the minute things went bad the the
psychopathic monster comes out
and that's what we need to avoid that's
what we need to look out for
that's what we need to prevent and the
only way we can do that is to
study the past and try and understand it
to the best of our ability
anything else dave
that's a rough one dude
this is just this has been a downhill
adventure from the word go man and it's
hard to listen to
you set it up i think really well at the
very beginning of the last podcast this
is these are not stupid people and it
gets reinforced
just like that final that little
conclusion you just expressing like this
understanding these are not dumb people
and the psychopathic trait of the
psychopathic tendency the thing that
might trigger that
in us
connected to the idea of humility is the
fear of being exposed for not being
smart or the fear of being exposed for
not knowing what to do or the fear of
being exposed for not understanding
what's going on
and how powerful that fear can be to get
you to behave in a way
i'm
i i wouldn't i probably wouldn't use the
word psychopathic very often to describe
too many people and it's it's totally
appropriate here yeah well it's weird
when you think of psychopathic you think
of someone that
thinks of their own self it so they
murder someone right so they make this
move and and and do whatever they're
gonna do that
negatively impacts you know some
other person or maybe a few people
you don't think of it of where it
impacts 12 000 people right
it's just 23 000 people yeah or 23 000
people it's just insane yeah and just
the thing i was thinking about too in
the and i'm trying to just make somewhat
of an objective reconnection to the
things we teach this idea of leadership
is
god i wish i wrote it down but the the
the the respect for your subordinates
the loyalty the loyal yeah the the the
the loyalty to your subordinates the
belief in their
just their basic welfare in this case
just their basic welfare
how liberating it is if you're
surrounded by people that know that you
care about them
to be like hey fellas
i don't know the answer to this one and
then like
no factors here we'll figure it out hey
i'm not really sure what we should do
here
sir no problem that we can we got this
and how many times the best thing i ever
did was tell my my subordinates my
junior marines that were junior to me in
the hierarchy the senior ncos mid-grade
ncos and be like hey
gunny what do you think i should do here
sir i've seen this 10 times here's what
i think you should do cool right on
and just the willingness to reveal that
you're not smart or reveal that you
don't have the answer or the willingness
to just be get past the fear of what
what will i look like if i don't know
and it's actually the best thing you can
do the best thing you can do is go hey
jocko dude i don't know what to do here
man
and if i actually
care about your welfare and they know
that
jocko will solve that problem for me to
help me figure it out a bit or or come
up with a thousand different ways that
we could try to make this thing work out
but if i succumb to that fear of
maybe this cost me my my my desire to be
the king of baghdad maybe this is the
one that exposes me and i cannot let
that happen
the ends the lengths that people are
willing to go to and i think you said it
that people are willing
people are willing to die before
tell me what you said i just they would
rather die than take an injury to their
ego then take an injury to their ego
yeah they would rather die than take an
injury to their ego and this is the case
where it's not their death it's the
death of tens of thousands of their
other people because they don't see them
as human beings and the hardest part is
is all the lead-up of
that crimean war the borah war like
world war ii world war one's coming war
one's coming we're not gonna learn these
lessons and you just see this this
tragedy coming because you know what
happens in history and like is this
really going to happen
and yeah this is this is really going to
happen
and that's i think that's what's made
this so hard for me is like man
we're not going to we're not going to
fix this in history so i just got to
listen to this story knowing exactly
what's gonna happen yeah you can't
change what you know is coming
you already know where this story's
going and you can't change it
and the the the other really scary thing
about this is
like i just said
these are people that you know a guy
like townsend he breezes through officer
selection he's freaking class president
at ocs right he's smart he's got some
dapper to him he's friendly he's
charming this guy's just a you know
winner all day yeah and he's surrounded
by people that aren't so he stands out
oh yeah
you know people say
i started off all these podcasts by
saying sometimes and this is certainly
true in the seal teams oh if you're in
the seal teams you know everyone thinks
that someone's in the seal teams they're
like incredible human incredible
whatever people think that about
everybody that's in the military oh this
person was a general this person was an
admiral they must be freaking awesome
and look there are tons of awesome
seals and tons of awesome admirals and
tons of awesome generals and colonels
yes we get that but occasionally you
look at when you go geez what just
happened where'd that come from and
here's where it came from
because inside these organizations they
if europe
you know i said this thing about i don't
forget what podcast i said it on
but i was talking about the fact
oh it was with daryl cooper
in
a bad organization the worst person
rises to the top
like the person that is willing to just
be totally ruthless is gonna like if you
take the nazis
who's gonna ride to the top the guys
that are willing to do whatever
those are the ones that rise to the top
they become the leaders
the mob who's willing to go out and kill
people and like those the people that
rise to the top
and unfortunately sometimes even in a
good organization a person with those
traits that can kind of kind of hide
those traits
they can still make it through the
wickets
and rise to the top and it's until they
get put under pressure that they go
and their and their true self comes out
well
good place to stop for today and we need
to be look at on the lookout for people
with uh psychopathic traits it's true
in the meantime
you know maybe we try and avoid having
those traits ourselves maybe we actually
try and become something a little bit
more positive
something good maybe we try and make
ourselves better
echo charles
what did you suggest
well psycho psychopathy
apparently from what i understand isn't
like
it's like a thing in your mind like a
normal seemingly normal person can be
an uh clinical psychopath it has less to
do with like crazy stuff that they do
it's just the inability to if i'm not
mistaken to empathize with people that's
one of the big problems yeah yeah so
yeah so it kind of makes sense where i
mean i don't know if he's making a
clinical claim clinical assessment
company or whatever but
if you if these people were psychopathic
that's what it would look like i'm gonna
say yeah if you
do what townsend did yeah and you're in
a villa
while your men are being butchered
starved tortured killed yeah you're a
freaking psychopath right right while
telling your leadership hey i think i
should get promoted and get evacuated
yeah it's like you just don't i mean
and do you think this and maybe this is
like maybe goes without saying or maybe
kind of obvious or whatever but
is this one of those situations where
you know how like you're such
so ahead of all the competition
in your organization or whatever your
team or whatever is so big where
victory is almost like a foregone
conclusion and you start caring about
other stuff like you get like these
individual self-interests that spring up
because the real goal and the real like
worry is kind of like
on the back burner now yeah i think
you're right i think that that's the
british army thought that they were just
right invincible yeah the british
military britain thought it was
invincible right right
so they're just more concentrated yeah
yeah like like okay
yeah you know we're gonna do that all
right that's obvious or whatever so lit
you know so now i start caring about
like
you know my the king of wherever and all
these other you know personal interests
or whatever i'm gonna say something that
i don't know maybe this makes me a
psychopath if i would have been in
charge of the british military i would
have assembled a hit team and we would
have gone and killed townsend like
execution style and brought his body
back
and said hey leaders
this is not how we lead
and to the question you asked too i
think given the author's education he's
using that term
in the clinical sense like that is not
like a a
it's not a slang term for a dude who's
kind of messed up he's calling him he's
referring to his psychopathic tendencies
he means that in the the medical literal
sense of that word right yeah exactly
that's what it felt like to where it's
like yeah 20 you know 23 000 people
dying and this guy doesn't care he cares
you remember when we set up the last
podcast this guy's background right
oh
see what's funny is i knew one of you
guys are gonna start making jokes about
that i didn't know when i didn't know
when and i didn't know who which is
interesting it was dave burke good deal
dave apparently but either way yes i'm
here now that
here now i'm here now yeah and i'm here
to let you guys know how to avoid
psychopath we're moving right into the
treatment
behavior because i don't know if one can
avoid actual psychopathy i think you're
either psychopath or not okay
okay but how can we at least make
ourselves a little bit better if we're
not it's like avoiding celiac disease
you know celiac disease
so it's like you can't avoid celiac
disease
but you can avoid gluten you see i'm
saying okay anyway
so
we talk about discipline the supplement
now not necessarily just discipline as
this was the supplement okay discipline
go ready to drink
energy drink a new era of energy drink a
new idea of energy drink indeed gluten
free by the way
nice nice
sugar-free sugar-free gluten-free
chemical chemical-free
um preservative-free because it's it's
pasteurized yeah so we're not going to
put any chemicals in your body yeah into
your temple
yes exactly right so so what you
need what you want what you expect from
an energy drink the good parts you get
that
no downside
but you don't get the drawbacks exactly
right the downside there's no downside
so me i just drink three okay i'm saying
i drink three today you drank three
today drink three today okay sir all
right i'm more healthy than i was before
that's why you guys feel like that's
pretty
okay many different flavors we're up to
what seven
flavors is that one no i think we're at
seven what's the best one mango hundred
percent dave what's the best one
it's nothing
well hey look hey mango's good i'm going
to say it right now i like mango
it's one of the better flavors i would
say
yeah so you know how like different
people like different flavors like my
middle daughter dax savage all day
dakota what do you got all day obviously
my son sour apple sniper another
psychopath i understand but my wife
going going the distance she'll she's
cracking open all kinds she's a she's
mixing it up party party mix
well the good news is they're all good
technically you're not gonna really
drink one and be like oh this one sucks
this can be pretty rare that's gonna
happen so i dig it and i understand but
technically yeah man but either way
whatever flavor you guys like look this
is the new the new era the new what do
you paradigm right that's the word
of energy drinks don't have to worry
about all that bad stuff
boom so yeah get get that uh also
stuff for your joints this is important
you might not think about it every day
it might excite some of us like other
supplements might
but
when your joints start acting up
then you'll be excited to have them not
act up so yeah you take joint warfare
super krill oil get on a routine too you
won't have to worry about your joints
anymore
there you go
true vitamin d3 cold war we got extra
protein if you need it in the form of
mulch that's the one to get excited
which you could call a protein called
dessert yes let's face it bro
it is so tasty you get done eating some
elk which by the way we're eating at the
villain household right now kind of a
lot
but sometimes you get done you're like i
wouldn't mind some dessert to go on top
of that fine meal i just had hey
but i don't want to eat ice cream i'm
definitely not eating cake because we're
not cake eaters over here no no no no
do you dave burke
do you put um like
no
foreign actually you know what i knew
that i think you told me that already
here's the thing that the frozen banana
the frozen like overly ripe banana
so every once in a while you won't blend
it up quite as good i need to make a
tulsi gabbard uh like drink we got i
think we got i think we got banana
coming maybe that needs to be the tulsi
gabbard flavor signature flavor
signature flavor of mulch
it's called over ripened frozen banana
yes there you go tea put that in if it
sometimes you don't blend it all away
let's say you're in a hurry or whatever
or maybe just not just thorough that day
whatever and then you'll get the little
chunks of the frozen banana in there
and it kind of feels like ice cream
it's a little treat you can trick your
kids with that too but they think it's
ice cream so yeah all right you can get
the drinks you can get all these things
at vitamin shop you can get all these
things at
jackalful.com you can also get the
drinks at wawa
we're working on a bunch of other stores
right now so um check it out there you
go also the free shipping situation oh
yeah and this is kind of a big deal
would you call it a subscription it is a
subscription okay subscribe to any of
these things like let's subscribe to for
sure joint warfare
subscribe to that for sure d3
you probably don't need to subscribe to
d3 because
it's got like
pills in there so like what are you
gonna yearly subscription is gonna show
up no you don't really need to subscribe
to that but super krill joint warfare
definitely and then
whatever your go-to milk flavor yeah
probably worth it yeah especially if
you're lifting
because say resistance training but if
you're lifting this let's face it that's
that's going to be the jam 100 all right
what else also origin usa this is where
you can get your american made like for
real american made for real
american-made jeans boots
geez geez of course for the jiu-jitsu oh
yeah plenty rash guards also for the
jiu-jitsu yeah in hoodies you know
compression pants
otherwise sometimes known as spats we
you ever wear spats no ever nope
the privacy of your own home why would i
wear spats in the privacy of my own home
you never know okay no whatever brad you
know there's some stuff that you do in
the privacy of your whole own home that
you're just not going to just talk about
freely i'm the same well okay yeah don't
act like you don't that's like you
didn't just catch me right there
that's like one of the dumbest things
i've heard in like two weeks what are
you even talking about that could or
could or that may or may not be limited
or not limited to spats is what i'm
saying i'm just saying origin spats okay
oh you're too good for this
talks really rapidly you know you you
know
anyway
american-made spats if you're into spats
whether or not jacqueline's or not
there's that they actually come out with
a lot of cool stuff
also like that heavy hoodie that they
got the heavy they're heavy
like it's not like heavier or warmer
hoodies is like a new thing but the
heavy yeah
it's
kind of a new thing it's insane so
they've done some good stuff over there
that original winter winter arrived by
the way in sd
yeah
i transitioned this morning to jock a
white tea in the morning like a warm
jack of lights
so
it's a little bit let's get a little
chilly gotta get out that heavy uh
originusa.com
originusa.com if you want to give me
that stuff true um yeah cool also we
have a store joco has a store we we all
it's all it's kind of all of our store
now at this point
uh it's called jacquo's store so you go
to
so you can get
by the way our store is not located one
quarter mile outside of our camp right
we're not doing so it is co-located in
our camp no we will not run out of
supplies in our camp no it's uh yeah
well you know it's online so
i guess it's relative but either way
discipline equals freedom shirts hoodies
some hats on there
a lot of good stuff on there uh if you
want to represent while you're on this
path while we are on this path if you
want to represent hard
or just a little bit jacqueline.com we
also have a subscription subscription
scenario some good designs coming out
some good designs on that if you get a
new shirt every month uh with some cool
fun
kind of layered
ideas going on your shirt some good
stuff good feedback on that one yeah so
far people are digging that one i also
subscribe to this podcast
the jocko unraveling podcast that i do
with daryl cooper dc
grounded podcast which we haven't done a
long time warrior kid podcast i know i
owe some of those you can also join us
on jackondeground.com
that's uh alternative
amplifying
podcast with some it's q a answer a lot
of questions for you all there's a way
to ask questions through that we're on
question we've done hundreds of
questions so far so if you want to tune
into that we also talk about
like i said ancillary but impactful
topics
and it's also uh we're we're setting up
this platform docker underground.com in
case
in case things get a little bit wild in
case we lose control
which we would be
losers if we didn't have a contingency
plan right
you could be look we i had to detach i
was looking at some of the things that
were happening in the world and i was
like we might get
this might turn into a problem yeah i
remember i called you i was like hey
dude we need a freaking backup plan yeah
yeah you're like it's going to cost
money we got to do this and i was like
okay well let's people will get in the
game
so if you want to get in the game it's 8
and 18 cents a month if you can't afford
that we still want you in the game email
assistance at jacquelineground.com if
you want to just support
if you don't have a place to go if we
get
banned
uh what else could we get caught off
inundated inundated with outside with
outside interests
all those things do you want to hear do
you want to hear uh the podcast with uh
a advertisement for
a mattress right as we're talking about
you know a tank battle yeah you don't
want to hear that just mess up the whole
you also by supporting that you keep
advertising out of this
thing
yeah it's true
also we have a youtube channel the video
version of this podcast if you don't
know what dave burke looks like boom you
can know so yeah or you know or like a
lot of people a lot of people are
watching and listening at the same time
newer ish medium kind of either way if
you want to watch it on youtube you can
we have a youtube channel also some
excerpts on there
so if you just want little nuggets
medium nuggets we'll say okay origin usa
has a cool podcast to subscribe to as
well psychological warfare i made an
album for echo charles kind of yeah time
what kind of
if you have little issues little moments
of weakness uh press play on your phone
after you download it from any mp3 place
and i'll tell you how to
how to push through that moment of
weakness flipside canvas.com dakota
meyer making cool stuff to hang on your
wall got a bunch of books final spin
you better pre-order that thing right
now if you want that first to dish
that's what i recommend um
it's getting some good reviews right now
from the
kind of like the terminator review
people
people that like to smash you in their
reviews have given it really
crazy good reviews yeah so
final spin dave what's your review
good it's so good
uh
check dc gave me a review the other day
because i gave it to dc and he read it
and he was like
he was freaking stoked so
um
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocols disabilities freedom field
manual way the warrior kid one two three
four mikey and the dragons hackworth
about face extreme ownership dichotomy
of leadership uh we have the leadership
company
where we teach leadership
echelonfront.com if you need details on
that that's where you can find out about
our live events including the muster
including field training exercises
ef battlefield
um we have an online training platform
you can hear us refer to it from time to
time if you want to ask me a question go
to extremeownership.com
and enroll in the extreme ownership
academy
and you can ask me a question you can
ask dave a question you can ask leif a
question
we're on there two three times a week
we also have a bunch of courses you can
take so check that out and if you want
to help service members active and
retired their families gold star
families you can check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got a charity
organization that does all kinds of
amazing stuff
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org and if you want more
of my boring blathering or you need more
of echo's interjecting inquiries or you
want dave's enhancing estimations you
can find us on the interwebs on twitter
on the gram and on facebook dave is at
david r burke echo zadek with charles i
am at jocko willink and thanks to all
the men and the women of the military
who are leading
not from a psychopathic mind but trying
to take care of their people and
accomplish the mission and also thanks
to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for taking up care of us by
locking up the psychopaths of the world
and to everyone else out there
take care of your people
take care of your people put them first
and you don't take care of them by being
easy or letting them cut corners or
allowing a lack of training and allowing
a lack of discipline you take care of
them
by helping them be the best they can be
by helping them be prepared by listening
to them by incorporating their ideas and
by putting your own agenda and your own
aspirations
below theirs
go do that
and until next time this is dave and
echo and jocko out